Fertig gekack-weighted.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, welche Programmiersprache wir heute nehmen, ob es Rust ist oder nicht,
vielleicht muss ich den Titel noch aktualisieren.
Also ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal was, ich habe nämlich das Tool von gestern noch fertig
gebaut.
Das ist vielleicht nicht die schönste Variante in allen Belangen, aber es funktioniert, ich
zeige euch das jetzt erstmal schnell.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin nicht scharf drauf, in Rust das zu machen, wir können das auch
in Go machen, wir machen das in unterschiedlichen Programmiersprachen und gucken dann mal am
Ende was wir draus lernen, wir müssen aber noch das.NET Programm komplett fertig machen,
ich denke mal so ein paar Minuten dafür brauchen wir noch.
Nein, C machen wir das nicht, also wir haben zur Ausfall Leute, nein, also wir haben zur
Ausfall.
Wir können das Tool, versuch mal in Go, in Pi, in Rust, in D++ habe ich nur für euch
reingeschrieben, das werde ich nicht machen.
Wir können es auch in Minochi erst oder versuchen in PowerShell, oh ne, das ertrage ich heute
nicht.
Also PowerShell, das könnt ihr mir heute nicht zumuten, das kann da knicken.
PowerShell mache ich heute bestimmt nicht.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz, ich zeige euch mal kurz die aktuelle Variante, ne, ne, PowerShell
machen wir für, ne, nix, nix, Desktop aufräumen, Desktop ist gut so wie er ist, Desktop ist
ein ganz normaler Ordner, Bambus Pionage für den Zap, Desktop ist ein ganz normaler Ordner.
So, ja, es ist schön das die Connection established ist, ich freue mich, Popup, jetzt ist sie
wieder disconnected, ok, lass mich raten, gleich ist es wieder established, PostChamp, Alter,
was will denn diese Anzeige da oben, F-Sharp, ne, ach ne, F++, was ist denn F++, so geht
das jetzt zur Abwechslung wieder, ok, also ich mache mal kurz einen Shithub Pull, ne,
gar kein, gar kein Shithub Pull, einfach nur ein Pull, Remote, Update, Git, Reset, minus
minus Hard, Origin Master, Git History ist natürlich beste Comet Messages, also ich meine,
warum sollte es nicht Kekkel sein, so, und so sieht das, wait a minute, warum ist das
kaputt, hä, warum auch immer ich das jetzt nochmal neu importieren muss, ok, meinetwegen,
ich weiß nicht, was da los ist, da war ein Regex, ja, ja, zeige ich euch gleich, aber
jetzt erstmal, ich will nicht gleich hier direkt loslegen, erzählt mal, gibt es irgendwas
spannendes neues, was man wissen muss, irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken mit neuen Logos, weil
ich meine, wir wissen alles, Sicherheitslücken heute ohne gescheites Logo geht nicht, ne,
die ist bloß, die ist doch gar nicht lang, 10 Zeilen oder so, ja, ja warum nicht, kommt
der in letzter Zeit nicht so selten vor, das da, ok, da kommt jetzt Rickroll, how to write
esoteric Javascript, JS Brainfuck explained, boah, alter, war da irgendjemand tatsächlich
so langweilig, dass da irgendeinen Brainfuck in, ja gut, ich meine, es gibt Cobol in Javascript,
ich meine, wer das noch nicht gesehen hat, Cobol.js, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, vor allem,
weil es sich hier handelt, wie auch immer man liest, dass das waistcoat machen so, all
dem geht gar nichts.
Ich hab sogar einen Artikel zu- Hey, Daily W- Also ich- Okay, Daily WTF. Wir bleiben mal bei der deutschen Aussprache.
Hab ich früher, äh, ja Daily gelegen- Oh, da ist aber auch mal ordentliches- Äh, wie hat denn mein Opa früher gesagt?
Auch ordentliches Geschoss da auf der rechten Seite. Ähm.
Das- Die Seite hab ich früher täglich, täglich gelegt.
Oh, das ist aber auch mal ordentliches- Äh, wie hat denn mein Opa früher gesagt?
Auch ordentliches Geschoss da auf der rechten Seite.
Ähm. Das- Die Seite hab ich früher täglich, täglich gelesen. Die hatten- Die hatten teilweise richtig geile Stories.
Die hatten, ähm.
Tree State oder so.
Den Artikel hab ich mir-
Ja, genau.
Nee.
Mein File not found.
Wo ist das? File not found.
Ja, genau.
Hier.
Das da. Also.
Das hab ich- Guck mal 2005.
Also ich hab die Seite früher mega, mega gern gelesen.
Ähm.
Weil die da immer lustige, lustige Stories aus so dem Programmiereralltag hatten.
Und irgendeiner hat bei sich im Source Code halt das hier mal gefunden.
Enum bool. True, false, file not found.
Und wir wissen ja alle, ein bool hat prinzipiell drei Sta- äh, drei States, nicht zwei.
Das hat sich bei mir so eingebrannt, das hab ich mir bis heute gemerkt. True, false, file not found.
Ja. Wie würde man das korrekt machen?
Das ist tatsächlich, ich mein, wir kennen den, der Quanten-Enum, der ist alles, ja.
Bis man nachguckt, weiß man nicht, was er ist.
Aber wir kennen ja nicht den Kontext so wirklich.
Aber wie würde man's richtig machen?
Keine Ahnung, man würde es auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht bool nennen.
In Kotlin hat bool four States.
In C Sharp kann ein bool, ein nullable bool, theoretisch sogar, äh, auch drei States haben.
Null und true oder false.
Äh, ja, genau, also ich, ich hätte, wahrscheinlich hätte ich's gar nicht bool genannt,
sondern ich hätte es irgendwie so, so was wie read status oder read, read result oder pff, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so was genannt.
Ja, und dann gibt's entweder file not found, could not open oder read error oder pff, keine Ahnung, ja.
Irgendwie sowas, aber, aber bestimmt nicht so in der Richtung.
Ja, bools in C sind ja auch eines der Sachen, die, ne, nicht so klar sind.
Mittlerweile geht's, mittlerweile geht's, bzw. ich weiß gar nicht, ob es in, in, im neuesten C Standard,
ich glaub, der neueste C Standard ist ja von 2010 oder so.
Dort, dort, wo es auch die neue Struct Syntax gegeben hat.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es einen richtigen bool-Type gibt mittlerweile in C.
Früher war das ja so, wo es auch die neue Struct Syntax gegeben hat.
Früher war das ja so, int wurde als bool verwendet, also quasi null oder nicht null.
Also 100, 3500 war true und 2 war true, alles, was nicht null war.
Das Standard bool klingt eher nach C++, ich meine jetzt wirklich C, ob die sowas, sowas haben.
Enums in Rust, ja, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Plupsy, Dankeschön für den Sub, Max, Dankeschön, Massive Subscriptions hier.
Du bist doch letztens, ich seh dich fast jeden Stream.
Ich mein, du spammst zwar eigentlich wenig und wenn ich dich fast spamm sehe, dann ist es eigentlich nur
dieses eine spezielle Emote, du weißt schon, was ich mein.
Aber ansonsten, du bist doch oft da, also ich krieg das schon mit.
Ah, ich muss gerade was sagen.
Alter Leute, heute ist brutalst warm, oder?
Hätte ich nicht meine Klimaanlage hier am Start, könnte ich wahrscheinlich gar nichts machen hier drin.
Ich hab sie gerade aus, aber das hat auch gut runtergekühlt.
Jetzt mach ich sie wahrscheinlich im Laufe des Streams wieder an.
Da hatte ich wirklich Glück, dass ich mir vor schon ne Weile her, ich würd mal sagen 4, 5 Jahren oder so,
hatte ich mir die ja im Frühling noch einbauen lassen, weil ich mir dachte, alter der Sommer wird bestimmt heiß,
der Sommer wurde auch heiß, aber jetzt ist es...
Und was auch eine sehr gute Entscheidung war, ist, die Klimaanlage sowohl ins Arbeitszimmer als auch ins Schlafzimmer einbauen zu lassen.
Schau, seht ihr das JS-Video noch an?
Vielleicht, ja, mir ist es aber grad nicht so sehr nach Brainfuck in Javascript.
Kommt in die... Moment, Moment, das muss oben rechts in GitHub stehen.
Maintenance Tool written in Rust.
Placing the fast, fantastic, fantastic, placing the fast maintenance tool written in Rust, written in pure Rust.
Weil ansonsten, kann sich jemand dran erinnern?
Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her, es gab so ein Web-Framework in Rust.
Actives, F, Act... Moment, Rust, Actifx, irgendwie so, Actix, Actix, genau.
Und das war weit und breit das schnellste und mit das beste Rust-Web-Framework.
Und irgendwann kam die Rust-Taskforce von Hacker News und Reddit und überall und haben den Autor genervt, weil er unsafe verwendet.
Und die haben den so lang abgefuckt, bis er keinen Bock mehr auf das Projekt hatte.
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, ich mach mal gucken, ob wir das noch finden.
Die haben den richtig abgefuckt.
Der wird seinen Grund gehabt haben und ganz ehrlich, den Autor der Library zu flamen dafür, dass er unsafe an manchen Stellen verwendet, wenn er es für richtig hält.
Das kann man auch anders machen, außerdem so sehr auf den Sack gehen, dass er das ganze Projekt einstellt.
Da haben sich die Rust-Leute wieder nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert.
Was ist die Alternative? Soll es in C++ machen, dann ist alles unsafe.
Niemand schafft es mehr als zwei Zeilen zu schreiben, ohne dass sein Code unsafet wird in C++.
Man kann es davon abgesehen, es schafft auch keiner mehr als zwei Zeilen in C++ zu schreiben, woran am Ende noch schlüssig erklären kann, was die Zeilen eigentlich genau machen.
Es gibt da so ein paar schöne Beispiele für besonders gut lesbaren C++-Code.
So eines meiner Lieblingsbeispiele ist folgendes.
Ich mache mal Wishlist Studio Code auf, damit ihr es mit Sonntags-Highlighting seht.
Habt ihr vielleicht Glück und könnt es besser erkennen.
Wer erklärt mir, was es macht?
Der Stringer ist übrigens mehr oder weniger eins zu eins von Stack Overflow kopiert.
Wer erklärt mir, was der Stringer macht?
Wer schafft es?
Das ist so hässlich, Alter.
Das habe ich mir mal von Stack Overflow runter kopiert.
Es kann sein, dass sie ein paar Zeilen vertauscht hat.
Ich habe hier eine Textdatei bei mir, die heißt C++ oder CPP Sackt.
Weil immer die Frage kommt, was Sackt an C++, habe ich mir ein paar Best-of-Beispiele reingeschrieben.
Das habe ich reinkopiert von Stack Overflow, weil ich so abfach fand.
Nein, das ist valid C++ Code.
Ich kann es euch mal ganz kurz erklären, was das macht.
Es ist ein Template.
Es ist eigentlich gar keine normale Funktion, es ist quasi ein Template.
Generics in anderen Programmiersprachen nur noch deutlich genericker.
Die kannst du auch mehr geschissen machen.
Du kannst deine Software komplett in C++ Templates programmieren, wenn du willst.
Was das Ding macht, ist, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, du kannst beliebig viele Argumente an diese Funktion übergeben.
Weil args und konst und dings und Punkt Punkt args, das expandet alle Argumente, die du übergeben hast.
Was das macht, ist, das erzeugt einen String aus allen Argumenten, die übergeben wurden, wenn ich das richtig zusammen bekomme.
Moment, die Musik ist ein bisschen laut.
Also das konkretet quasi alle String-Argumente, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das ist quasi so etwas wie join args, ja genau.
Und man hat das gebraucht, weil irgendjemand wollte eine Logging-Library bauen, wo du Strings angeben kannst,
der sollte die zusammenhängen und davor und danach noch Datum und Zeit und Color machen.
Und dann war die Antwort von Stagoverflow, ah, it's easy, just use new argument forwarding syntax.
Und dann kam dieses Beispiel hier bei Stagoverflow raus.
Wir können ja mal suchen, ob ich das noch finde.
Könnte sein, dass es das hier sogar war.
Okay, so war es ähnliches, so war es ähnliches. Guckt euch den Scheiß an, Alter.
Also C++-Leute müssen ein gewisser Mensch sein. Guckt euch das mal an, was denken die sich dabei?
Ich meine, allein schon, dass sowas überhaupt valid-syntax ist, sollte man sich mal überlegen, was da los ist, oder?
Ich muss aber dergelegenen noch mal eine Sache erwähnen, weil manchmal wird mir auch gefragt, ob ich alles an C++-Kacke finde.
Nein, ich finde Templates an sich hat durchaus coole Möglichkeiten und vor allem auch die ganzen Compile-Time-Check-Geschichten.
Hups, das wollte ich jetzt nicht aufwarnen.
Die du in C++ machen kannst, du kannst ja zum Beispiel in C++ checken, ob die String-Länge stimmt, die übergeben wird zur Compile-Zeit.
Also du kannst in C++ quasi ein Template und ein Compile-Time-Check machen, der guckt, ob deine Methode oder deine Funktion aufgerufen wird mit Strings, die vielleicht länger als 15 Charakter sind und sowas.
Das kannst du in keiner anderen Programmiersprache, die mir so einfällt.
Zur Compile-Zeit machen, da fällt mir eigentlich C++ ein, was sowas kann.
Du kannst Runtime-Checks machen und dann irgendwelche Fehler werfen, ja das funktioniert, aber Compile-Time-Checks, sogar noch mit einer, naja gut, sinnvollen Fehlermeldung nicht, da fällt mir aus der C++ nichts ein, wo du das machen kannst.
Das finde ich tatsächlich an C++ gar nicht so schlecht, aber die Umsetzung ist halt so, wir und, ah, ne, ne, das ist, das ist, ne, ne, das ist kein, das ist C++, es wäre ja langweilig, wenn und, und, wenn und, und Pointer wären, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Und, und sind in dem Fall keine Pointer und keine Reference, das sind glaube ich L-Args oder irgendwie so, wie heißt das in C++?
Halt mal, C++, L-Reference, L-Result, ne, R-Value, das kann, ne.
Wobei Kenpachi hat glaube ich Recht, das könnte der Move-Operator sein.
Ne, Moment, hier ist es doch, und, und, int, x, Moment, das ist R-Values, R-Values, hier.
Das sind, das sind R-Values und L-Values, fragt mich bitte nicht, was das ist und was es macht und was der Sinn davon ist, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung.
Naja, egal, das wollten wir heute aber gar nicht, weil ich wusste, man kann sich ja oft ein bisschen ranten über C++, ich glaube, das gibt keine Möglichkeit, die man da auslassen sollte.
Oh, Phi-Fat-Time, letztendlich ist doch wurscht, ob das Ding mathematisch bewiesen ist oder nicht, ja.
Solange das funktioniert, was rauskommt, das ist halt so der Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Praxis.
Es ist ja schön, wenn das alles super krass mathematisch bewiesen ist, wenn der Compiler aber nicht ordentlich optimiert das Zeug raushaut und tausendfach hinter GCC oder was auch immer für die Sprache sinnvoll ist zurückfällt, da bringt dir das gar nichts.
Es sei denn, du brauchst, machst irgendwelche was weiß ich zertifizierten Raumfahrtsanwendungen, Medizinanwendungen, was auch immer, okay.
Das ist was anderes. Microsoft hat ja auch mal versucht Hyper-V, und ich weiß nicht, ob die das immer noch machen, oder was soll ich denn da suchen, Hyper-V Proof oder so, die haben das,
ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, was ich suchen soll, die haben zumindest mal versucht Hyper-V von MT-Mathematiker den Source-Code quasi beweisen zu lassen, dass der Source-Code das Erwartete macht und keine sonstigen Effekte hat.
Ich vermute mal, das war aber nur ein Marketing-Gag, weil das durchaus ein bisschen teuer sein könnte, könnte ich mir vorstellen, weil sowas zu beweisen, stelle ich mir dann auch gerade für so ein, ja das Ding,
ich weiß nicht, wie viele Zeilen Code Hyper-V hat, aber dürften nur ein paar hunderttausend sein wahrscheinlich, klein ist das sicherlich nicht, das stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Also genau weiß ich nicht, was die gemacht haben, ich vermute mal, ich kann es nur vermuten, ich vermute mal, die haben definiert, was bei gewissen Input-Parametern denn das gewünschte Verhalten ist,
und dann wurden die einzelnen Funktionen bewiesen, dass sie nur dieses gewünschte Verhalten oder halt nur das, ja nur dieses gewünschte Verhalten aufweisen können.
Ja und ne, ich habe welche, ich benutze die aber relativ selten. Ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was die machen, es gab damals aber sogar zu Hyper-V,
ähm, wie heißt das bei Microsoft nochmal, Channel 9 glaube ich, hieß das damals, hieß das diese Microsoft, was heißt das mal, heißt diese Microsoft Video Developer, genau,
Video von Microsoft zu, wo sie das gemacht haben, das war wahrscheinlich eh bloß Marketing-Gag. Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Der Go-Compiler ist in Go geschrieben, ja das ist ja mittlerweile bei den meisten Programmiersprachen so, zumindest ab einem gewissen, ähm, Fortschrittgrad.
Der initiale Compiler ist oftmals in was anderem programmiert, also ich weiß es von Rust, der ursprüngliche Rust-Compiler war glaube ich ganz am Anfang in C,
danach in O-Kammel, wie auch immer man das genau ausspricht und, ähm, dann selbst in Rust.
Hier die Unterlagen, ja, exzellent, exzellent, Five-Hat-Time, das ist Chat, Leute, das ist es hier, alles klar, Five-Hat-Time.
Max, was sagst du zur Go vs. Rust-Debatte, was soll ich dazu genau sagen? Also ich finde die Programmiersprachen haben durchaus ihre Überschneidung, aber auch unterschiedliche Einsatzgebiete, also
ich sehe das nicht so sehr als Konkurrenzkampf, wenn ich ehrlich bin, Rust ist die deutlich komplexere Sprache, also Rust ist wahnsinnig kompliziert im Vergleich zu Go,
Rust ist komplett unmanaged was Speicher angeht, also keine Garbage-Collector-Geschichten oder sonst was musst du selbst machen oder eben die Rust-Magic erledigt deine Frees.
Ähm, ich glaube die Anwendungszwecke für was die Sprachen genutzt werden, ne, für was die Sprachen gedacht sind ist glaube ich auch was komplett anderes.
Go hat ja erklärt das Ziel eine Einsteiger-Programmiersprache zu sein, die leicht verständlich ist, dieses Ziel hat Rust garantiert nicht und sollte Rust dieses Ziel haben,
ähm, dann haben sie versagt, aber das Ziel hat Rust nicht, also Rust ist definitiv keine Einsteiger-Sprache und auch keine Sprache die einfach zu lernen ist.
Dafür wird wahrscheinlich geschwindigkeitsmäßig und ja optimierungspotentialmäßig Rust, wenn das von fähigen Rust-Programmierern versus fähige Go-Programmierer gemacht wird, in die Tasche stecken.
Dafür hast du aber wahrscheinlich komplexere Programme deutlich schneller in Go implementiert als in Rust.
Und am Ende ist der Laufzeit wahrscheinlich gar nicht so das Entscheidende, das sind halt unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke, also ich würde sagen so krass die Konkurrenz würde ich da gar nicht unbedingt sehen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt wann es denn kommt. So, aber ich switch mal kurz rüber, ich zeige euch mal, dass das Programm funktioniert.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken ob mein, äh, Dingsmanager noch funktioniert, also ich zeige euch mal kurz, dass es funktioniert.
Das ist übrigens noch kein Rust, ja, sieht man ja auch daran, falls jetzt irgendjemand sagt, Max, aber im Titel da steht Rust, warum ist das kein Rust?
Anzeige ist raus, Twitch Mods sind benachrichtigt, da steht was falsches im Titel, ne, das ist noch kein Rust.
Also was sagt der Netzmuffel, ich habe mir zu Beginn von Corona auch Go angetan, aber Rust war einfach wunderbar, das stimmt, da hast du recht.
Da geben die sich Mühe, das müssen die sich aber auch, weil Rust ist so komplex und hat so viele Sachen wo man drauf achten muss, wenn da die Beschreibung nicht gut wäre, wäre komplett unbenutzbar.
Also ich glaube das ist eines der Hauptpunkte, weshalb sich Rust so gut hält.
Also neben dem, dass die Sprache an sich gut ist für das wofür sie gedacht ist, aber die Beschreibung in Rust ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
So bei Go bin ich schon in zwei Probleme, in Dinge gerannt, wo es der Goverflow geschrieben hat, dass man Unfug machen muss, also den Code, den ich nicht verstehe, wie das C++ Beispiel von vorhin.
Ja, das C++ ist ja auch nicht zum Verstehen gemacht.
Bei Rust habe ich zwar solche Sachen schon gesehen, also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Go Syntax finde ich an vielen Stellen auch ziemlich pepega, aber die Rust Syntax ist auch echt nicht ohne, gerade die ganze Laufzeit, ne nicht Laufzeit, die ganze Lifetime Decorator Geschichte und sowas.
Also ich würde sagen prinzipiell kommen die Leute mit Go sicherlich einfacher zurecht als mit Rust.
Also wenn du jetzt irgendjemand, der weder groß Ahnung von Rust hat noch groß Ahnung von Go hat, Go Source Code vorsetzt und sag mal ungefähr was der macht und Rust Source Code vorsetzt und sagst dem ja erklär mir ungefähr was der Source Code macht, dann wird er dir das bei einem Go Programm wahrscheinlich deutlich einfacher erklären können als bei Rust.
Äh nein, das kenne ich, das war mal ein Mailweb Interface vor 20 Jahren, falls das noch irgendjemand kennt.
Das sieht auch aus wie letztes Release 2013 oder so, ja so sah das damals aus, das kenne ich noch ja.
Aber ansonsten, das sieht besser aus als SAP, ja gut, aber ne das kenne ich nicht.
Generell würde ich nie exotische Programmiersprachen nehmen und wisst ihr das hat schon einen ganz praktischen Grund, umso mehr exotische Programmiersprachen du nimmst, umso weniger Leute findest du die sich damit auskennen.
Und du hast ja vielleicht mal auch ein Projekt, was du nicht alleine machst oder vielleicht ist derjenige das alleine macht auch mal weg und Rust ist auch schon schwierig im Business Umfeld, ja also ich würde es mir, also mal angenommen ich wäre irgendwie Projektleiter, was ich nicht bin, nicht werden will und hoffentlich auch nie machen muss.
Aber angenommen ich wäre Projektleiter und wir hätten irgendwie die Aufgabe, was weiß ich, irgendwie Anbindung an ein Inventarmanagementsystem, irgendwie so ein Business Enterprise Crap und da kommt dann einer zu mir und sagt, Max lass das doch mal in Rust programmieren, so für Maximum Performance und Rust ist geil.
Dann würde ich ihm wahrscheinlich sagen, ja ich weiß Rust ist geil, aber was machen wir denn, wenn die einzige Person die Rust kann nicht mehr hier ist, wer soll das denn weiterentwickeln und also du findest ja schon für Rust nicht so wirklich gut Leute, um damit was großartiges zu machen.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich notgedrungen sagen, wir machen das in.NET oder in Java, ich meine als Projektleiter musst du auf andere Sachen gucken, außer auf ob dir das technisch gefällt, ja wir würden das in.NET machen oder in Java oder in Javascript oder in, na gut PAP würden wir das eher nicht machen.
Ja, sowas, wie drei Sachen würde ich wahrscheinlich vorschlagen, weil da finde, oder GO, GO vielleicht auch noch, sagen wir mal vielleicht in Java,.NET, GO oder Javascript, also das würde ich dann wahrscheinlich vorschlagen, weil da findest du wenigstens Leute, die davon Plan haben.
Und wenn du es jetzt halt in Rust machst oder in ZIC oder in zx beliebige Random Sprache ein, da findest du halt keinen.
Nee, ich kenne das, habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert.
Was hältst du von der.NET Maui?
Ok Leute, ich habe das Gefühl, heute kommen wir nicht großartig zu Rust, wenn ich jetzt noch nicht mal die.NET Seite fertig habe, aber na doch, doch, sag mal, wir machen jetzt auf 5 Minuten Schwätzen und dann fangen wir an.
Also, was hältst du von der.NET Maui?
Wenig, ich würde sagen, ich halte den Abstand von Maui und ich habe auch vor von Maui weiter Abstand zu halten.
Also ich hielte schon von Xamarin nicht sonderlich viel.
Und Maui ist ja quasi die neue Reinkarnation von Xamarin und ich weiß nicht.
Ihr wisst, ich mag dort.NET und C-Sharp, aber das hat mir ehrlich gesagt nie zugesagt.
Worauf ich gespannt bin, ist, ob jetzt, wenn es Go Generics gibt, ob es, wie es da so mit, ich nenne es mal Funktionalen, Libraries aussieht, dass du so ein Select mal machen kannst oder einen Filter auf den Array oder eine Summe über Array-Elemente und solche Geschichten.
Würde mich sogar nicht wundern, wenn es das schon gibt.
Die Go Generics haben einen ekelhaften Sonntag, die habe ich tatsächlich noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Was ist denn mit dir los?
Doch, du hast recht, da habe ich gerade gar nicht dran gedacht.
Da drin könnte man das tatsächlich auch machen.
Da würde man auch Leute finden.
Nee.
Leute, wollen wir das mal auf die Tagesordnung schreiben für einen der nächsten Streams?
Ein Desktop. Der Desktop ist ein ganz normaler Ordner, wie alles andere auch. Dementsprechend sind da Sachen drin.
Link ist vor allem Standard Library.
Hast du viel Erfahrung mit JavaScript?
Warum man heute noch Lua verwendet, ist mir auch nicht ganz klar, ehrlich gesagt.
Zumal ja schon mal alles sus ist, was Arrays bei 1 anfangen lässt.
Hey, ich versuche gerade ein All-in-One-Dev-Enf in Docker zu bauen.
Das ist schon schwierig. Du kannst in Docker in der Regel nur einen Prozess starten.
Ich habe herausgefunden, wie man mehrere.NET-Versionen installiert.
Bei global config kann ich die SDK-Versionen einstellen.
Wie setze ich eine Club?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin jetzt in fast 20 Jahren noch nicht in die Situation gekommen, da was in der Richtung machen zu müssen.
Du schreibst doch normalerweise die Version in dein Projekt-File.
Warum machst du eigentlich einen All-in-One-Dev-Container?
Ist nicht gerade der Vorteil von Containern eigentlich, dass du einen passenden Container für das jeweilige Projekt bauen kannst?
Aber gut, kann jeder machen, was er will. Ich kenne ja das Projekt nicht.
Aber trotzdem haben wir viele Streams.
Doch, ich glaube schon.
Wobei, ich glaube nicht, oder? Ich glaube, wir haben nie was in Java gemacht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, ich glaube nicht.
Ne, nur Javascript.
So, also gut, ich switche mal rüber. Ich zeige euch mal das, was ich fertig gebaut habe von gestern.
Also, folgendermaßen. Ja, und das ist noch kein Rust.
Ich habe Fachinformatik als Systemintegration gelernt, 2007. Ja, nicht Anwendungsentwicklung.
So, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, ich glaube, mein Modus ist aktiviert. Also, ich zeige euch jetzt mal zumindest, was man machen kann.
Als erstes führen wir das mal aus..NET, RUN, minus minus help.
Also, was wir jetzt machen. Übrigens noch mal zusammengefasst für das, was wir gestern probiert haben.
Also, warum lädt der Alert Manager immer nicht richtig? Was ist das eigentlich?
Also, Sinn und Zweck der ganzen Übung ist.
Eigentlich zwei grundsätzliche Sachen. Einmal, weil ich das Tool wirklich bauen will für die Arbeit, weil ich das sinnvoll finde.
Wir haben nämlich oftmals das Problem, dass die Leute vergessen, wenn sie Wartungsarbeiten auf Servern durchführen
oder auf Systemen durchführen, es ist auch egal, ob das in der Cloud ist oder offline.
Oder was ist offline? Vor Ort. On-Prem, wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Die Leute vergessen ganz gerne mal Monitoring Silences einzutragen.
Und sind dann zu faul, wenn sie quasi schon den Reboot eingetippt haben, beim Support anzurufen
oder beim Monitoring anzurufen und sagen, hey Jungs, da gibt es gleich Fehlermeldungen.
Deswegen habe ich überlegt, man könnte ein Tool auf alle Systeme drauf machen, egal ob lokal oder Cloud,
mit denen man Instant-Downtimes für die Systeme setzen kann.
Für standardmäßig 15 Minuten. Das heißt, du musst dann einfach nur noch Set-Downtime machen
und ausführen und dann kriegst du 15 Minuten Silence.
Kannst deine Reboots machen, deine Wartungsarbeiten machen, das Ganze ist wieder da.
So. Und ich habe ich für Testweise einen Alert-Manager aufgesetzt,
weil unser ganzes Alerting und Monitoring Zeug funktioniert mittlerweile mit Prometheus über Alert-Manager.
Warum ist denn das Ding eigentlich so procken?
Übelgeiler Conor, schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast.
So. Und. Geht doch.
IHK-Video. Welches?
Das mit der Abschlussprüfung?
Bekommt das eine Systemd-Unit?
Nee, wozu? Das ist ja nichts, was die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund läuft.
So. Also zumindest, was man aufrufen kann, ist... Moment, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich,
ich bilde das mal kurz
wartet mal
publish
Single File
Bild
Ich wollte nicht Linux, arm, alter
Linux
x64
System DSing, ja aber wozu sollte das
was
was die koreanische
Translation Datei ist gelockt
Leute, mir war bis jetzt noch nicht mal bewusst, dass ich überhaupt koreanische
Translation in meinem Tool drinne hab, aber gut
ah jetzt funktioniert's, ok
Bild
mv, das Ding soll nicht postchamp heißen, sondern später soll z downtime
oder ja
wir können es auch downtime now
ich weiß, ich hab dir eine gute Idee, wie man das nennen kann, ich nenn's einfach mal
set downtime
und wenn man das Programm jetzt ausführt, set downtime, aber minus minus help
dann kannst du verschiedene Sachen da drin machen, also du kannst dir die aktuellen
Monitoring Maintenance Einträge für das System anzeigen lassen, du kannst die
für das System löschen
oder du kannst eine neue
downtime eintragen oder Monitoring Silence
und wenn du das Programm einfach nur ausführst, ohne was einzustellen
dann
macht er folgendes
dann macht er Emojis, weil Emojis ist prinzipiell immer wichtig
die Rakete fehlt noch als Emoji
so zumindest geht er dann zum Alert Manager
hier, Alert Manager
und setzt eine Maintenance Downtime für das System
also sprich, der sagt dir
am besten alles klein
so zumindest sagt er dir, Monitoring Silence is created, startet jetzt, hast 15
Minuten Zeit
der Autor ist der Max und
Maintenance ist halt die Standardmeldung, die kommt
ich hab noch ein paar weitere coole Features eingebaut
Set downtime klein
also ich hab noch ein paar weitere Features eingebaut, zum Beispiel
Emojis im Terminal geht mittlerweile ohne Probleme, du brauchst aber die
passende Emoji Schriftart dafür
ich hab glaube ich
Tweemoji
das da
da geht das, mittlerweile geht das einfach
so ich hab noch ein paar zusätzliche Features eingebaut, sonst wäre das
ganze nämlich zu einfach geworden
jetzt kann man sich die
aktuellen Downtimes für das System auflisten lassen
und sieht, aha, es gibt aktuell eine
hat 20.47 gestartet, endet 21 Uhr, 13 Minuten left
von mir erstellt und sowieso
dann kann ich, wenn ich mit meiner Maintenance fertig bin
ne, unter Windows-Batch machen wir das garantiert nicht
wenn ich fertig bin mit meiner Downtime, dann kann ich die auch einfach wieder
clearen
dann sagt er, so, alles wieder entfernt und ihr seht hier auch gibt keine mehr
mach jetzt noch mal eine
und ich hab noch ein paar andere ganz praktische oder finde ich zumindest
praktische Features eingebaut, zum Beispiel
wenn man das mit sudo verwendet, dann checkt ja trotzdem, wer den
wer die Downtime erstellt hat, pass mal auf, also
ich tu jetzt mal so, als wäre ich Ruth
oder machen wir es anders, ich werde einfach mal Ruth
Ruth, Ruth at Poggers
ich geh nach
home
max repos postchamp, da liegt das halt
und ich führ das mal aus
und jetzt passt mal auf, und jetzt passt mal auf
ich bin Ruth, ja
set Downtime
und trotzdem weiß der, dass der Autor Max ist
ganz automatisch
ja woher weiß er das denn
weil ihr könnt davon ausgehen, wenn Leute sich auf die Systeme verbinden
das erste was die machen ist sudo minus i
ich kenne keinen Admin
der überhaupt in seiner Bash History oder in seiner ZSH-Config
was drinne stehen hat
das steht alles unter Ruth, das erste was ein Admin macht ist sudo minus i
ich kenne keinen wo es anders ist
aber
jetzt, dass man auch mal ein bisschen Linux Sachen hier wieder lernt
falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet
wenn man mit sudo Ruth geworden ist, gibt es eine Environment Variable
die sich sudo user nennt
und in sudo user steht drinne
welcher User man vorher war
bevor man Ruth geworden ist mit sudo
das heißt da kann man nachgucken, was war das für ein User vorher
und dementsprechend
und dementsprechend erkennt er sudo minus i, minus i ist interactive
also normalerweise kannst du ja sowas machen wie sudo
who am i, so dann führt der ein Kommando aus, nämlich welcher User du bist und dann sagt er
natürlich Ruth
wenn du minus i machst startet er
interactive, also im Prinzip es heißt er startet eine Shell
jetzt ist natürlich der Unterschied
was ist der Unterschied zu
jetzt kommt es, jetzt die Frage an den Chat, mal gucken wer
wer die 5 Head Krone des heutigen Tags gewinnt
was ist der Unterschied zwischen sudo minus i
und sudo bin bash zum Beispiel
tja wer weiß es, wer weiß es
wer gewinnt, wer gewinnt den 5 Header des Tages
nein der cleart nicht alles silences
weil der filtert nach Hostname und ob in dem Kommentar
ein Marker drin steht
Login Shell, ja das ist
das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt
und ich hoffe dass ich euch jetzt kein Mist erzähle
aber
ich gehe davon aus, dass ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe
der Unterschied zwischen sudo bin bash und sudo, ich kanns euch zeigen, guckt mal enf
hm fällt euch da was auf
und jetzt mal was sudo, sudo minus i enf
sieht anders aus oder
oder auch nicht
doch sieht anders aus
also
meiner
Erinnerung nach ist es so, dass sudo minus i
die Login Skripte ausführt, die laufen wenn man normalerweise
sich mit ner Shell einloggt
also dass der auch die passenden Environment Variable und alles mögliche
setzt, so als hättest du dich wirklich
als root eingeloggt
und wenn du sudo bin bash machst
dann führt der einfach nur eine bash aus
ohne das root environment alles zu laden
also in der Regel willst du sudo minus i haben und nicht sudo bin bash
ja und der Unterschied zwischen sudo und su
ist
nicht wirklich
nicht wirklich ein großer, nur dass du quasi
root wirst um dann root zu werden
aber der Unterschied zwischen su und su minus ist interessant
weil su minus ist mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche
su minus ist auch Login Skript oder kein Login Skript
minus s weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht was es macht
minus s macht shell run shell specified bei shell environment Variable
da kannst du anscheinend überschreiben was es für ne Shell sein soll
ja also sudo minus i
bei su minus gibt es keinen sudo user
ja das wäre logisch an der Stelle
weil es führt ja, es startet ja auch nicht sudo die Shell
sondern sudo führt ja nur
so aus was dann den Login macht, ja stimmt wenn du sudo su machst dann geht das nicht
das ist richtig hier
also es würde mich wundern wenn das wäre, das können wir ausprobieren
aber das wäre sinnvoll ja genau
und da funktioniert es, da sieht man dass da scheinbar keine Login Skripte gelaufen sind
ok
röpel danke schon für den sub
so genau muss ich nicht sein
achso ich fang das ab ich fang das ab ja ich kann euch auch das
das funktioniert wenn es nicht gesetzt ist wenn es nicht gesetzt ist dann nimmt
er den aktuell eingelockten User
genau so also da hätten wir uns wieder was bisschen für den Bildungsauftrag getan
nö
mach ich nicht
oh nein erklärt nicht alle Silences also dann erkläre ich euch das mal kurz was ich
was ich da programmiert habe achso ich wollte euch ja noch ein weiteres Feature zeigen
guckt mal wisst ihr was man auch machen kann wenn man nämlich eine Ticketnummer
angibt
also man kann ja angeben warum man
man kann ja angeben warum man jetzt eine Silence im Monitoring einrichtet ja
so und wenn ich da beispielsweise reinschreibe minus R weil Reboot und das
ganze steht dann in Ticket
CAC
12345 drinne
das ist ja durchaus eine Meldung die ganz interessant ist ja
Reboot und die Details stehen in diesem Ticket drinne
passt mal was der da draus passt mal auf was der da draus macht
der fügt den Jira Link ein zu dem jeweiligen Ticket
ne das läuft alles über Environment Variable
dafür ist auch der Regex genau
und jetzt kann irgendjemand der im Alert Manager guckt
und sagt aha da sind Silences eingetragen für das System
übrigens nicht die richtige Silence
alter was ist da mit meinem Alert Manager los
ach super man das ist nicht anklickbar na gut
egal dann kann das dann kann das Copy Pasten und und direkt das aufmachen
CACL.DE ist registriert das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht
ja ich soll alles alles expiren
so also das das habe ich eingebaut
ähm ansonsten eigentlich
alles mehr oder weniger wie erwartet
nicht geht
Set Downtime minus minus Help
oder ja oder minus H geht auch
genau du kannst im Prinzip noch angehen wie lange deine Downtime sein soll
und ob sie später starten soll fertig
wieso heißt Chell überhaupt Chell das weiß ich nicht
keine Ahnung
funktioniert das wenn du in den in den ne das glaube ich nicht ich denke mal die
es capen ich denke mal die es capen das probieren
probieren wir es doch mal aus
ach so Moment CACL
oh was
ich hätte fast irgendwas kopiert ich weiß nur nicht wohin
irgendwas aus der History
view
weiß nicht probieren wir das mal Edit
ne ich glaube nicht dass man hier inline
ich glaube nicht dass man hier inline ähm
HTML machen kann
das das wäre schon
ist das ist das richtig chat
ist das ein Link
ne das geht nicht
das funktioniert nicht
ich mein vielleicht wenn wir es über die AP machen
weil wenn wir es über die AP machen dann dann escape das vielleicht nicht
aber das wäre dann eher ein Prometheus Bug
so und jetzt zeige ich euch mal noch kurz wie ich das gemacht habe ich sehe schon mit Rust wird das heute nichts
zeige ich euch mal kurz wie ich das gemacht habe also
Einstieg ist
also das hier unten könnt ihr alles vergessen also alles alles ab hier ist unsinnig das sind irgendwelche Jason Parsing Sachen
so also Einstieg ist hier
Einstieg ist hier
das sind die Kommandozeilen Argumente das haben wir gestern schon gemacht das kennt ihr ja also wir haben Kommandozeilen Argument List Clear
das könnte man übrigens noch schöner machen das Tool unterstützt auch Commands und Subcommands also
ich müsste das nicht alles
ja ja ich denke auch dass der das escaped
also ich wollte jetzt aber nicht unnötig aufingenieren das ganze also man kann
List angeben Clear angeben entweder Duration angeben Startzeit angeben oder ein Kommentar angeben
dann guckt er erstmal ob es List ist also sprich ob man
Setdown Time minus L macht
und dann
wenn man Setdown Time minus L macht
welche Lip das ist Specter
Specter Console heißt das Ding
so gucken wir uns mal List Silences an was der da macht
der ruft sich eine Liste mit Silences von der von der API ab
hier oben drüber ja
der holt sich den Hostname vom
System auf dem es läuft
dann geht er an die Alert Manager URL
und ruft Silences ab
über HTTP
und dann filtert er das ganze noch nach Silences die nicht expired sind
und nach Silences wo im Comment
Setdown Time drin steht irgendwie muss ich meine Silences markieren die ich
gesetzt hab ja
dann sortiert er das nach Endzeit und gibts zurück fertig
so Silences dann guckt er noch ob er welche gefunden hat weil er keine gefunden hat
dann sagt er gibt keine was wäre deine Go to Lip für Configs in.NET
du meinst sowas wie Yammel oder JSON Configs
ja gut für JSON Configs also du brauchst du brauchst eigentlich gar kein extra
Lip du kannst die ganz normale
Option und Configuration
API verwenden die eingebaut ist
warte mal
appsettings.json
das Ding muss übrigens nicht Appsettings heißen
boah meine Augen
noch mal gerade gerade gesaved
also du kannst eigentlich das eingebaute verwenden von denen
für Configurations
ja die Beispiele sind wieder pepega von denen hier
der eskept das trotzdem Luca ich glaube das können wir vergessen die Beispiele sind wieder
richtig
richtig pepega hier von Microsoft
also
Moment ich muss mal kurz was nachgucken
Moment
genau ok also jetzt
also wer hat wer hat das noch mal gefragt mit den mit den Configs
ja genau also ich würde ich würde das eingebaute verwenden weil dann hast du
Support für alles mögliche
und in der Handhabung ist es an sich auch total einfach
nur Microsoft hat wieder eine beschissene Hilfe Seite dafür
also du kannst du kannst zum Beispiel einfach wenn du eine Web Anwendung hast
oder eine Commando Zeilen Anwendung oder was auch immer
kannst du einfach sagen
services
nee warte mal nicht Services Configuration
Configuration add
JSON File
config.json das wars
mehr musst du nicht machen
du brauchst da keine extra Library
und dann
wenn du das achso du kannst übrigens noch sagen alternativ optional true zum Beispiel
falls du Default Werte hast
und sobald du das gemacht hast und jetzt irgendwas aufrufst
was
du hast zum Beispiel ein Commando ja also ein Shell Command
was Cackle heißt
und das gibt Hello World aus oder gibt irgendwas aus deiner Config Datei aus
dann kannst du sagen also nachdem du das da oben eingefügt hast
nachdem du das hier eingefügt hast kannst du dann sagen ok ich hätte gerne
eine i-Configuration
und schon hast du die kompletten Inhalt deiner Config Datei hier drinnen zur
Verfügung
Run Cackle
ich hoffe das geht so was ich gemacht habe
ach nee
ich mache immer noch ja guck hier da ist der Configuration Manager
du kannst aber auch du kannst aber auch
eine
Typed Configuration machen also du kannst für dein Config File also
wenn du hier jetzt anlegst config.json
App Settings Jason
oder nee config nennen wir das config
dass man sieht dass man das nicht
dass man das nicht nach dieser komischen Microsoft
Geschichte benennen muss ja
config.json
und da kannst du hier alles drinne machen und hast dann Zugriff drauf
so dass das funktioniert
du kannst es auch Typed machen da machst du eine extra Klasse für die
wie ist das aufgebaut
und weißt du was das beste ist wenn du das eingebaute
das eingebaute Config
Parsing
ja im Framework das eingebaute Config Parsing verwendest
du kannst die Sachen in deiner Config Datei
sogar per Environment Variablen überschreiben
also pass mal auf was haben wir jetzt zum Beispiel gesetzt Logging
Get Section
Logging
das ist jetzt nur so hässlich
wenn man keine Typed Config hat
Log Level
Get Section normalerweise ist das
Typed und dann muss man das nicht so eklig machen
sondern hier keine Ahnung Default
wenn ich das jetzt ausführe
hat er aus meiner Config Datei eingelesen
äh
achso war mein Job Value vergessen
du hast Recht Hupe ja das geht auch aber da hab ich grad nicht dran gedacht
ja du kannst das auch mit Doppelpunkt machen klar
aber du siehst er hat Debug eingelesen aus der Config
der Hupe hat übrigens Recht man kann das auch so machen
ich verwende das nicht allzu oft
du könntest auch sagen Logging Doppelpunkt
Log Level Doppelpunkt Default
das wird auch funktionieren
oder aber was noch besser ist
du sagst Get
und hast fast einen Typ vorher definiert
was das
was deine Config eben
was in deiner Config eben drin steht
ja also sagen wir mal zum Beispiel du hast hier irgendwie eine Config
wir machen das einfach einfach nur Log Level
oder einfach nur Logging
und komm wir machen es noch einfacher Cackle
Cackle ist True
True 0W
beste
beste Config so muss so muss eine gute Config aussehen
und dann kannst du jetzt kannst du jetzt sagen okay ich hab ne Klasse
und jetzt kannst du halt einfach
ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt was ich hier mache
ja funktioniert guck True oder hier
Hawk oder so
so und was was daran auch schön ist
wenn du das wie gesagt wenn du das eingebaute Config Parsing und Config Zeug
verwendest
also so kannst du auf die Config Datei zugreifen aber du kannst auch
da weiß ich jetzt aber aus dem Kopf nicht wie es geht ich hoffe das steht in
der Microsoft in der Microsoft Doku drin
du kannst auch sagen was war das Prefix
oh fuck wie ging das
oh keine Ahnung
da müsste ich da müsste ich nachgucken Prefix
stell das hier hin Prefix
ach hier Add Environment Variables
Variables
kannst du sagen
und jetzt
kannst du sogar per Environment Variablen
deine Config überschreiben
also myCustomPrefix also mein Programm ist
ist QtChat ist mein Prefix
so also ihr seht aktuell ist meine Config, mein Config Eintrag ist
Cackle und der Wert Pog
gibt da aus
wenn ich jetzt allerdings sage Export QtChat
ähm
ist gleich 0
und ich jetzt noch mal ich hoffe ich habe es jetzt in der richtigen Sonntags gemacht ja
und dann funktioniert nicht
oh wie muss man das noch mal angeben
jetzt geht es jetzt jetzt funktioniert es jetzt jetzt funktioniert es
und so kann man das sogar überschreiben
das heißt im Endeffekt
du hast jetzt
Support eingebaut
für JSON Style Config Dateien
die auch mit der Standard Dependency Injection funktionieren
die du typisieren kannst so dass du eine Klasse wo die Config plus
du hast automatisch den Support drinne
bestimmte Config Parameter per
Environment Variablen zu überschreiben
also ich finde ganz ehrlich
bei der Funktionalität im Standard
in der Standard Lip brauchst du eigentlich den Rest nicht
ach ja stimmt
habe ich das coole Sache habe ich auch noch vergessen
du kannst doch sagen Reload
Reload on Change
und dann sorgt der automatisch dafür dass wenn du während die Anwendung
läuft die Config Datei anpasst
dass der automatisch sobald der hier so eine neue Configuration Klasse
anfordert das nachgeladen wird
man kann es auch Subscriben den Change das ist dann aber ein bisschen
komplizierter
man musste dann mit mit mit Option und und und und Gedöns rum machen
aber das ist jetzt das ist bisschen zu viel zu viel des Guten
so ich mach das mal wieder rückgängig weil das hat eigentlich mit dem was wir
machen wollen überhaupt nichts zu tun
ja ja
mach alles alles weg
ok dann eben nicht
dann lösche ich es halt so wieder
äh glaub nicht glaub nicht glaubt gibt kein kein Comments Comments Support
mal gut Jason Kommentare gibt es ja eh im Standard nicht ich weiß nicht ob es da
irgendwelche
ähm
irgendwelche Custom Extensions gibt oder so
ja so und
was durchaus sein kann ist dass es mittlerweile sogar Yammel Support gibt das
weiß ich nicht ob es
aber es gibt bestimmt eine Library die
das standardmäßige
Config Framework auf Bord auf
Yammel Support
bestimmt auch auf auf auf Tommel und Inni und sonst was
ok Moment es gibt wirklich Inni
ok ich hab nichts gesagt ihr könnt sogar Inni Files verwenden
aber das ist Microsoft es wundert mich nicht
Microsoft steht auf Inni Files
ich weiß ich kann die Yammel mittlerweile kann irgendwas gescheites
xml
ok also ganz im Ernst wenn ich die Auswahl hab zwischen Inni, Jason und xml dann würde ich
tatsächlich Jason nehmen
xml das ist das ist typischer Microsoft Shit dass es xml ist
was ist so schlimm an Inni Files
ja ja
nix aber ich sag mal so nesting
nesting ist halt in Inni Files
kann man kann man configs nesten in Inni Files überhaupt also
ich mein in der Jason Datei kann ich sowas machen ja
ich kann sagen hier
global settings
ähm
timeout
ah keine Ahnung 30
wie würde ich das in der Inni Datei machen in der Inni Datei könnte ich höchstens sagen
global timeout
gleich 30
und dann müsste ich alles immer prefixen und so
ich weiß nicht Inni ist
pepega shit
gibt's nicht global
auch vielleicht
ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
wie das wie das bei Inni Files ist
ob die mit warum haben die eigentlich mit
WTF das passiert wenn man nicht in seiner vm drin ist
haben die eigentlich mittlerweile jammel support
das gibt's aber bestimmt auf GitHub von irgendwelchen Leuten
anscheinend haben Leute schon jammel config gemacht so
also
noch ganz kurz weil irgendjemand wissen wollte
wofür der Regex ist
also wie gesagt so kann man Silences listen
das Clearen ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche
der
ruft sich alles Silences ab und löscht die dann
und das eigentliche zum Silencesetzen also sprich wo dann auch am Ende im
Alertmanager was rauskommt
ist
mehr oder weniger noch das was wir gestern Abend hier im Stream gemacht haben
das einzige was ich noch eingebaut habe ist
dass er standardmäßig wenn man
kein Kommentar angibt für die Silences, dass er standardmäßig Maintenance reinschreibt
und dass er immer hinten dran
in Klammern set downtime
dran hängt alles Kommentar
danach kann ich nämlich am Ende filtern um rauszubekommen ob das die Silences sind
die von meinem Tool gesetzt wurden oder nicht
dann habe ich ein
Regex für den
für das Jira Ticket, für den Ticketfilter
der guckt einfach ob das
ein Keck Ticket ist also
fängt es mit Keck minus an
gefolgt von beliebig vielen Zahlen
dann ist es ein Jira Ticket
kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten ob das ein guter Regex ist vielleicht sollte man das
noch eingrenzen auf
ähm
vielleicht sollte man das noch eingrenzen von 1 bis 5
hat jemand schon mal Jira oder von 1 bis 7
ich glaube mehr als eine Million
Jira Tickets in einem Bereich hat noch keiner geschafft oder
dann match das nicht auf irgendwelche unsinnigen Sachen
so hier bin ich mir nicht sicher ob das eine gute Idee ist
der guckt halt ob er
das Ticket findet und ersetzt das dann durch die Jira Uhr
hier sucht er raus welcher Autor für das
für die Silence eingetragen wird
also er guckt ist Sudo User gesetzt Joho Dankeschön für den Sub
er guckt ob Sudo User gesetzt ist wenn Sudo User nicht gesetzt ist nimmt er den normalen User der eingeloggt ist
dann holt er sich den Hostname und dann setzt er über die
über die Alert Manager API die Silence
und dann macht er nur noch ein bisschen sinnlose Konsolenausgabe dass es schick aussieht
fertig achja und natürlich
Copyright ganz wichtig dass alle wissen dass das von mir ist
so fertig mehr macht das nicht das alles
Leute ich ändere mal den Titel wir kriegen das mit Rust heute in 45 Minuten nicht mehr hin
ich ändere den Titel mal in Zeug von gestern fertig machen
so zack das im Titel was sinnvolles drin steht
was bedeutet warte das du meinst du meinst das da
frag mich jetzt nicht wie der Operator heißt aber ich kann dir sagen was er macht
der guckt ob das null ist ich will nicht dass es mit jedem Präfix geht
es soll gefälligst bei uns nur mit dem Präfix gehen die Maintenance Tickets haben
by the way der Maintenance Präfix ist übrigens nicht keck nur so das habe ich jetzt nur
für uns eingetragen vielleicht sollte ich vielleicht soll ich das hier oben
noch reinschreiben also keine Chira Präfix oder so Präfix
also das wir quasi sagen hier so ach nee mein Dollar
Moment ne ne Moment Moment Moment das packt jetzt rum weil ja so
Also ich wollte das hier erklären, also was der Operator macht ist, der checkt ob Start
Null ist und Start kann Null sein, weil Start ist ein Nullable Date Time, der checkt ob
das Null ist und wenn das Null ist, weist er ihm ein Default Value zu, also im Prinzip
ist das hier die, genau, das ist ja cool, guck mal man kann das tatsächlich direkt transformieren
lassen, also das ist quasi die Kurzschreibweise davon und die etwas längere Variante ist
das da, ja gucken ob Start Null ist, falls nein dann Start verwenden und ansonsten das,
ich weiß nicht seit wann es diesen Operator in.NET gibt, aber das ist der, alter auf
deutsch wieder guckt euch das mal an, der Nullzusammenfügungsoperator oder der Nullsammelzuweisungsoperator,
das ist unter anderem der Grund warum ich den Kram alles auf englisch stehen hab, weil
du findest im Internet definitiv wenn du nachversuchst nichts zum Thema Nullsammelzuweisungsoperator
und der ist seit C-sharp 8 drin, also spricht noch gar nicht so alt, seit 3 Jahren oder
so gibt es den erst, genau das ist der Nullcoalescingassignmentoperator, in C-sharp muss Null explizit erlaubt sein,
das kann man so nicht beantworten, es kommt drauf an für was, also normalerweise, also
der Unterschied ist folgendes, du hast in C-sharp grundsätzlich 2 verschiedene Typen von Objekten,
du hast structs und du hast, du hast structs und du hast Klassen, Klassen sind immer Referenzen
und structs sind values, so und values können eigentlich nicht Null sein, Klassen weil sie
Referenzen sind, also Instanzen von Klassen können Null sein, so und irgendwann ist Microsoft
mal auf die Idee gekommen, naja vielleicht möchte man ja auch das Value-Types Null sein
können und dann haben sie diesen komischen Fragezeichenoperator eingeführt, also normalerweise
kann Timespan oder DateTime nicht Null sein, weil es ein struct ist, aber wenn du ein Fragezeichen
dahinter machst dann darf es Null sein, ein String kann von Haus aus Null sein, doch?
Weil String ist ja auch kein Struct, sondern eine Klasse, wobei Strings in.NET so eine
Eigenheit sind, das sind Klassen, ja genau das ist ein Shortcut für Nullable, das sieht
man auch daran, wenn ich mir hier anzeigen lasse was Start ist, ah ne das zeigt nicht,
ja aber Nullable DateTime ist die längere Schreibweise davon mit dem Fragezeichen.
Ja und der wrap dann quasi deinen Value-Type in ein Reference-Type und du kannst Null checken,
ist manchmal ganz praktisch, in dem Fall ist es praktisch, weil für Kommandozeilen Argumente,
wenn du das Fragezeichen weglässt, dann geht er davon aus, dass das ein Required Argument
ist, also sprich wenn ich das Fragezeichen weg mache und ich versuche das Programm auszuführen,
dann sagt er mir, aufkompilieren wir ein bisschen, achso ja funktioniert nicht, weil ich das dann
unten ändern müsste, dann würde er mir sagen Start ist Required, ich kann es nicht ohne
den Startparameter ausführen, deswegen Fragezeichen dran, ja und das bei String ist wieder was
anderes, das kommt aus ganz unterschiedlichen Zeiten, String ist standardmäßig ein Reference-Type,
String kann eigentlich immer Null sein, aber man hat seit ein paar Versionen ist man auf
den Trichter gekommen, dass es vielleicht gar nicht so gut ist, wenn alles zu jeder
Zeit Null sein kann und man konnte es in.NET aber nie so richtig verbieten, weil naja es
war halt bisher so, du kannst halt nicht nach 11 Versionen von einer Sprache auf einmal sagen
so fundamentale Sachen wie Reference-Types können nicht mehr Null sein und so, das geht
nicht, da machst du ja alles kaputt, was die letzten 20 Jahre jemand programmiert hat,
so und deswegen hat man jetzt folgendes eingeführt, man kann in seinen Projekt-Settings Nullable
Reference-Types aktivieren, so und wenn ich das mache, dann kann ich auch Reference-Types
explizit markieren als darf Null sein oder darf nicht Null sein und wenn ich den Reference-Type
damit dann nicht markiere als darf Null sein, dann sagt mir der Compiler oder besser gesagt
der, dieses Analyse-Ding, sagt mir dann an manchen Stellen zum Beispiel, Moment mal,
ergibt doch keinen Sinn, weil, was sagt er, genau, dann sagt er mir das kann doch gar
nicht Null sein, genau darum String fragt, dann sagt er mir, warum, guck mal, jetzt hab
ich gesagt, hier guck mal, ich hab ihm gesagt String kann nie Null sein und jetzt sagt er
mir an der Stelle, naja aber, wenn String doch die Null sein kann, warum machst du dann
hier einen Check für Null und setzt ein Default Value, also der erkennt jetzt, dass es unsinnig
ist, was ich mache, weil, wenn ich ihm sage String kann die Null sein, muss ich auch nicht
checken, ob er Null sein kann, ja aber, eins muss man noch dazu sagen, wenn du nicht noch
zusätzlich sagst, dass das ein Error sein soll, ist das nur ein Warning, warum, naja,
weil es 20 Jahre lang C Sharp Code gab, wo eben Reference Types Null sein können und
wenn ich jetzt eine Library verwende oder irgendeinen Package verwende, wo das eben
der Fall ist, dann wäre das kaputt, deswegen ist es standardmäßig so, dass es nur ein
Compiler Warning ist, wenn ich Mist baue, aber, reicht ja auch erstmal.
Das ist übrigens nicht zur gleichen Zeit entstanden, Nullable Value Types gibt es
schon ewig, gibt es schon seit 15 Jahren oder so, Nullable Reference Types gibt es
glaube ich erst seit 2 Jahren, noch nicht so alt, mittlerweile ist glücklicherweise
die Standard Library selbst zum größten Teil hiermit ausgestattet, ja, genau, so,
wo haben wir denn unser Docker-File vom letzten Mal, das brauche ich jetzt, wo ist es denn,
hier, sonst noch irgendwelche Dinge, weil nachdem wir heute kein Rust mehr machen können,
habe ich jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit für irgendwelche.NET Fragen und Sachen,
die es so gibt Leute, weil mit Rust müssen wir heute nicht mehr anfangen, es war einfach
zu kurz, eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, aber dann
müsste ich Reboot umlinken, ich will Reboot nicht umlinken bei uns auf den Servern, wer
weiß was das für Auswirkungen hat, das lasse ich lieber, keine Ahnung, ist ein Ref Struct
Nullable?
Ne, ich glaube nicht, da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher, weil das ist ja bloß
eine, also es bleibt ja weiterhin ein Struct, also ein Value Type, nur dass dieser Value
Type per Reference übergeben wird, also ich rate ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen zusammen,
ich bin mir da nicht so sicher ehrlich gesagt, verwendet man äußerst selten, also ich würde
sagen ein Ref Struct ist nicht Nullable, aber ich vermute du kannst ein Nullable Ref Struct
machen, da kommen wir aber in so esoterische Bereiche, wo ich nicht weiß ob das jemand
macht, ja, doch doch doch darfst du, also wenn du eine 20 Jahre alte Lib verwendest darfst
du Nullable Config setzen, was du nicht setzen darfst ist, dass du Nullable als Error behandeltst,
du kriegst dann halt vielleicht ein paar Warnings an den Stellen, wo du die Library verwendest,
dass der Compiler sagt, hier guck mal da an der Stelle, es sollte eigentlich nicht Nullable
sein, aber es hat Null, also du darfst sagen, ja ich möchte Nullables verwenden, aber du
darfst nicht sagen, dass du das als Error behandeln willst, dann gehts nicht, hast du
eine Idee wie man das Java denken aus die SharpRausbuku, weiß ich so groß ist der Unterschied
doch gar nicht, ist doch kein riesen Unterschied ist es doch jetzt auch nicht oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, noch gar nicht, ich kann das nennen wie ich will, ich programmier den
Kram und ich bin letztendlich auch derjenige, der bei uns die Sachen mercht, was bei uns
ins Config Management reinkommt oder nicht, also ich kann den Kram programmieren, mein
Pullrequest selbst genehmigen und sogar selbst auf allen Servern ausrollen, also ich kann
es nennen wie ich will.
Es gibt mittlerweile so viele Überschneidungen, ich bin ja auch kein Admin, ich bin offiziell
DevOps Engineer, deswegen ist das auch DevOps TV, weiß ich nicht, was in Java Namespace
ist wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche, Namespace ist einfach zum kopieren von deinen Klassen,
sonst nix, falls du beispielsweise Klassen hast, die gleiche Namen haben, kannst du die
unterschiedlichen Namespaces packen oder kannst du was machen wie Namespace Frontend Backend
oder sowas wie Infra oder was recht beliebt ist, sind Leute die ihre Anwendungen, ihre
Web Anwendungen strukturieren so nach, dass es gibt ein Infra Projekt, ein Domain Projekt
und ein Business Projekt mit dem jeweiligen Namespace drin und sowas, ja für Kleinkram
kann man es auch übertreiben.
Meine Lieblingssprache, meine Lieblingssprache ist eindeutig C-Sharp, ist mit die erste Sprache
die ich gelernt habe, gefällt mir bis heute immer noch am besten.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit ist das meiste in Java, ich meine wir sind eine Business
Enterprise Stonks Bank, da ist die meiste Zeug in Java, aber mit dem Java Zeug habe
ich glücklicherweise nicht viel zu tun.
Ne mache ich nicht, oder mache ich je nachdem wie man es sieht, also aktuell regt mich mein
aktueller Arbeitgeber ziemlich auf bei vielen Sachen, aber ich mache das gerne, ich mache
die Technik gerne, was ich nicht gerne mache ist den ganzen Tag mieten, heute Leute, pass
mal auf, heute, ich weiß nicht ob ich euch das schon mal erzählt habe, aber heute hatte
ich, Dokumentationsmeeting, es ging um 9 Uhr los, Dokumentationsmeeting, danach Change Runde,
danach Status zur aktuellen To Do's, danach Daily Nummer 1, danach Daily Nummer 2, danach
für irgendwelche VPN Tunnel, Konfigurationsdinger und danach noch mal Gruppenrunde und das war
um 15 Uhr vorbei, also ich habe gemietet quasi von 9 bis 15 Uhr mit einmal eine halbe Stunde
Unterbrechung um 10 und Mittagessen um 12, eine halbe Stunde Unterbrechung, nice, oder?
So muss das sein, so stellt man sich den Arbeitsalltag vor.
Oh, das ist ne gute Idee Leute, das ist ne gute Idee, das gefällt mir, das ist ne gute
Idee.
Der Chat ist wieder feifett, das finde ich ne gute Idee, aber ne, ne, ne, ich will ja
nicht automatisch ne Silence setzen bei nem Reboot, ich will bewusst ne Silence setzen,
ne ansonsten ist das nicht.
Ja, das sind Sachen, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf, also Projekt Sachen würde ich
nicht machen, das ist vor allem nicht in der Firma wo ich jetzt bin, sowas so viel verdiene
ich nicht, nicht so dass ich irgendwie krass reich werde durch meinen Job oder so, also
ich verdiene jetzt nach diesen, es gab jetzt nochmal Tarifvertrag, Erhöhung und es gab
noch Zeug, dann irgendwie noch 6 mal, jetzt bin ich jetzt ungefähr bei, ich würde sagen
so irgendwie ungefähr 80.000 Euro im Jahr, wenn man 5 Tage arbeiten würde, ja, ich arbeite
nur 4 Tage, also was weiß ich, mal 0,8, also ungefähr so in dem Dreh.
Ja, ja und ne, ich mein in Frankfurt ist das, also Frankfurt im IT Sektor und, also man
muss das auf zwei Arten sehen, es ist viel, wenn man das mit dem Durchschnittsgehalt
vergleicht, ja ok, gib mich zu, da habt ihr recht, da ist das viel und wenn man das mit
ganz vielen anderen Leuten vergleicht, die verdienen bestimmt deutlich weniger, das
ist richtig, aber worauf ich das bezogen habe ist, wenn du das mit IT in Frankfurt vergleichst
und auch ungefähr ähnliche Tätigkeitsbereiche, ich mein ich hab mittlerweile 12 Jahre, ich
weiß nicht, wenn man mal die Ausbildung weglässt, ja, ich hab 12 Jahre Berufserfahrung, ich
kenn mich ziemlich breit aus, ich mein guck mal Leute, wir haben in diesem Stream mehr
oder weniger alles gemacht, was es gibt, außer Druckerpatronen getauscht, von Microcontrollern,
von Frontend bis Backend, GitHub Actions, Git Reboot, Config Management, Ansible, Terraform,
Sets Encrypt, Hochverfügbarkeitsgeschichten, Load Balancer, Cloud Infrastruktur, Provisioning,
alles möglich, also das müsst ihr wirklich zugeben, also gerade an die Leute, die länger
dabei sind, jetzt mal ernsthaft, wir haben in diesem Stream alles, Cobol, wir haben Cobol
gemacht schon mal im Stream, ja, Game Dev, das stimmt, das haben wir tatsächlich nicht
gemacht, Game Dev ist wirklich nicht meins, aber wir haben mehr oder weniger alles, wir
haben Steckdosenleisten geflasht, wir haben Sachen gelötet und gebastelt, wir haben alles
in dieser Richtung irgendwie gemacht, also ich kenn mich tatsächlich relativ breit aus,
ich mein Linux ist eindeutig das, wo ich mit Abstand die meiste Erfahrung habe, also generell
so das ganze Linux Umfeld und natürlich auch die ganzen Sachen, die dazugehören, ja, also
ich weiß, wie man Load Balancer baut, ich weiß, wie man Linusystem ordentlich absichert,
wie man Linusystem ordentlich konfiguriert, ich kenn mich mit Config Management aus, ich
kenn mich mit Versionsverwaltung aus, es gibt da schon ein paar Sachen, wo ich mich nicht
nur mal reingeguckt, sondern relativ gut auskenne und das ganze, wie gesagt, wir machen das,
was man heute DevOps und Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery nennt, das machen wir,
das hab ich mit eingeführt bei uns auf der Arbeit damals, da wusste ich nicht mal, wie
der Kram heißt, damals noch mit einem eigenen GitLab Repo, was mir die Firma dann irgendwann
verboten hat, weil sie gesagt haben, nein, nein, ihr dürft keine eigenen Repos mehr haben,
benutzt mal bitte alle unser Bitbucket und ab da wurde es kacke vom Händling her, mittlerweile
in GitHub wieder ganz okay, tja und wenn man das mal misst mit anderen Stellen, sagen wir,
mit dieser Berufserfahrung und so mit dem Kenntnisstand und dem Gebiet und das dann
auch noch Frankfurt dazu gibt, dann sind 80k wiederum nicht übermäßig üppig.
Also das ist halt die Frage, wie man es sieht und jetzt im Ernst, wer würde sagen, gib
mir nicht mehr, also wenn ihr beispielsweise nach links und rechts guckt und in Frankfurt
einen Job seht, die ähnliche Sachen machen oder vielleicht sogar Angebote habt, die mehr
geben, warum sollte man dann sagen, ach ne, ich hab's mir überlegt, also ne, ne behalt
mal lieber das Geld, es ist doch sogar in dem Fall sinnvoller, ihr nehmt die Kohle und
wenn ihr sagt, ihr braucht das nicht, macht irgendwas sinnvolles damit, spendet es an
euer Tierheim, ich glaub jeder kann dieses Geld besser gebrauchen als euer Arbeitgeber.
Nehmt, macht mit eurem Gehalt was ihr wollt, wenn ihr mehr Geld bekommen könnt, nehmt
mehr Geld, warum nicht, niemand würde sagen, ne, ne reicht schon.
Ich bin 37, Säuferhardware haben wir schon gemacht, ja ich mein, ich war mal früher
richtig harter Turnschuhadmin, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet hab, ich war regelmäßig
im Rechenzentrum, ich hab da Zeug verkabelt, ich hab sogar mal irgendwann CCNA gemacht
vor ein paar Zeiten, nicht, dass es irgendjemand heutzutage interessieren würde.
Also ich kenn mich doch recht breit aus und in vielen Bereichen auch ziemlich gut, wenn
ich das so von mir selbst mal sagen darf, ja, ja davon kommst du ja in München, du
kriegst ja nicht mal die Wohnung bezahlt, tja, kommt drauf an wahrscheinlich welcher Provider
was du da als Niedungsadmin machst, also ich hab meine Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht
als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration und hab danach auch dort noch ein bisschen gearbeitet,
nicht ultra lang, aber lang genug, ich hab ja dazu übrigens mal ein Video gemacht, wenn
der Chef dich verarscht, hieß das glaub ich, Google Auto verschwäuft, wenn der Chef stirbt,
also das wünsche ich keinem, ja, warum ich meinen Job gekündigt hab, ich hab ja mal
ein Video zugemacht, warum ich da weg bin, ja und was denn Niedungsadmin beim, also was
wollte ich jetzt sagen, also ich hab danach gearbeitet, aber das war halt 2010, das kann
man nicht mehr vergleichen und damals haben die mich auch abgespeist, abgespeist mit irgendeinem
Hungerlohn, irgendwie 33k oder was weiß ich oder 35k, ich glaub 33k war mein allererstes
Gehalt nach der Ausbildung, da kecken die Leute heute, da arbeitet keiner mehr für und
das ging dann aber relativ schnell auch mit dem Wechsel, ich glaub ich hab da nur noch
eineinhalb Jahre oder so gearbeitet und dann bin ich woanders hin gewechselt und da ist
dann auf einen Schlag auch mehr geworden, ja, aber wie gesagt für Frankfurter Verhältnisse
geht da durchaus mehr, wie ich mir den Kram merken kann, gar nicht, deswegen bin ich 90%
der Sache am googeln, das wichtige ist doch, dass du weißt wovon du quasi sprichst, sodass
du die passenden Begriffe kennst und danach suchen kannst, auswendig wissen kann doch
den ganzen Kram heutzutage keiner mehr, deswegen finde ich auch die ganzen Zertifizierungen
ein bisschen unsinnig, wenn ich ehrlich bin, weil bei Zertifizierungen, gerade bei Microsoft
Zertifizierungen, werden irgendwelche auswendig gelernten Dinge abgefragt, ja, ich hab beispielsweise
mal eine, nee nicht nur, eine mehrere Azure-Schulungen gemacht, weil die Firma, wo ich Arbeit der
Meinung war, ja durch Azure-Schulungen lernt man was, ich bin der Meinung, war die unsinnigste
Zeitverschwendung überhaupt, aber da konnte man dann auch so Test, so Zertifikat-Test
und Testfragen machen und wisst ihr wie Microsoft Azure Zertifikate und Azure Tests auch sehen?
Du kriegst dann eine Frage gestellt, zum Beispiel, ähm, sie konfigurieren eine virtuelle Maschine
im Azure-Portal und möchten eine Public IP einstellen, wie geht das und die wollen,
dass du in diesen Zertifikaten wirklich reinschreibst in diesen Fragen, ähm, klicke links auf
Menü Expand, klicke auf Azure-Portal, klicke auf virtuelle Maschine, klicke auf virtuelle
Maschine erstellen, klicke auf Interfaces, klicke auf externe IP zuweisen, das wollen
die, dass du da reinschreibst und du kannst da nicht nachgucken, du sollst das auswendig
wissen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch mal eine Azure-Zertifizierung gemacht hat, ob das noch
so ist, aber ich gehe davon stark aus, weil diese Schulungen, die ich gemacht habe, sind
auch erst 2 Jahre her und das ist kein Witz, das fragen die wirklich und das ist halt so
hirnlos, weil du kannst das einfach nachgucken, du musst wissen, was du machen willst, ja,
du willst, du willst, ähm, Assign Public IP, IPv4 Azure machen, VM, das suchst du
und du hast es nach 5 Minuten, nach 5 Minuten, nach 30 Sekunden gefunden, das musst du nicht
auswendig wissen.
Ich kann gut googeln und, hey, eine Sache, nur mal für den Fall der Fälle, ne, falls
sich irgendjemand, das will ich ja nicht, das will ich ja nicht, falls sich irgendjemand
schlecht fühlt, weil das hier im Stream vieles einfach aussieht, muss ich an der Stelle jetzt
vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, ich habe oftmals schon Sachen, die ich im Stream zeige, vorher
ausprobiert, es ist nicht so, gut, das hier nicht, das hier habe ich gestern da zusammen
gewusst, aber das ist ja auch kein kompliziertes Programm gewesen, aber gerade wenn wir irgendwelche
Cloud Setups machen, wo wir dann beispielsweise mal Load Balancer mit Let's Encrypt Certificate
und 3 Backend Server, Automat, das habe ich im Vorfeld schon mal ausprobiert, ist nicht
so, dass ich das im Stream, auch wenn es manchmal so wirkt, alles immer hier blind mache, dass
ich gar keine Ahnung davon habe und oftmals ist es auch so, ich habe die Themen vielleicht
zufälligerweise mir für die Arbeit mal angeguckt in noch nicht allzu langer Zeit her und da
ist das Know How noch frisch, das ist alles fake und staged, genau, also da muss ich keiner
irgendwie schlecht fühlen, dass ich das alles irgendwie aus dem Ärmel schütteln würde
oder so, ist nicht so, habe doch gestern gesehen, guck mal, und heute, wir haben heute keinerlei
Progress gemacht, ich habe nicht eine Zeile programmiert und ich bin eine Stunde 40 on,
also was das angeht, bin ich sicherlich kein Vorbild, was die Produktivität angeht, wobei
man halt auch sagen muss ja, Stream und wirklich was geschafft bekommen wollen, es sind ja
zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, im Stream sitze ich hier, sag was zum Chat, erkläre
mal ein paar Sachen und zeige dann beispielsweise das mit den Reference Types und solche Geschichten,
das ist natürlich was anderes, wie wenn du auf dem Rechner sitzt und denkst, ok, das
muss jetzt mal fertig werden.
Welche Schulungen haben dir gut gefallen?
Keine, keine Asher Schulung, war alle Mist.
Ich habe mir aber eine gute Ausrede abgeguckt von dem einen, von dem einen Asher Schulungsdozent,
habe ich eine wunderbare Ausrede abgeguckt und zwar, ich überlege gerade, was wir den
gefragt haben, wir wollten, wir wollten irgendwas wissen, wir wollten irgendwas wissen, so und
er wusste es nicht, oder es war vielleicht auch nicht Teil der Schulung oder keine Ahnung,
ich weiß gar nicht, was der Hintergrund war, zumindest wollte er nicht sagen, es ist nicht
Teil der Schulung und er wollte auch nicht sagen, er weiß es nicht, der hat dann sinngemäß
sowas gesagt wie, ah ja Thema XY, interessantes Thema, allerdings muss ich sagen, dieses Thema
ist woanders verortet und dann hat er weiter gemacht und wir haben uns angeguckt und haben
uns gedacht, was wollte er uns damit jetzt eigentlich genau sagen, dieses Thema ist woanders
verortet, habe ich mir gesagt, hä, was soll das sagen, aber er hat dann einfach weiter
geredet, so als wäre nichts gewesen, so nach dem Motto, ja also mit dieser Antwort müsst
ihr jetzt mal gefällig zufrieden sein, das Thema ist woanders verortet und das habe ich
mir gemerkt und wenn jetzt irgendwie sowas blödes kommt, kann ich das als Ausrede bringen
und die Ausrede funktioniert tatsächlich, also merkt euch das, wenn ihr es nicht wisst
oder nicht sagen wollt, was los ist, sagt ihr einfach, also das Thema ist aktuell woanders
verortet und dann sehen die Leute irritiert und gut ist, woanders verortet, ja, ne machen
wir auch nicht, Spiele programmieren juckt mich tatsächlich wenig, also ich hab gestartet
mal mit 33k, ach meiner fisi Ausbildung, ne bestimmt nicht zu wenig, klar, also es ist
doch ganz klar, der Chat ist mittlerweile so high IQ, so großkopfig, dass man, wenn man
den Stream dabei war und sich komplett angeguckt hat, wenn man diesem Thema zumindest im Lebenslauf
schon mal ein plus bei Kenntnissen hinschreiben kann, also wenn es drei plusse gibt von Einsteiger,
Fortgeschrittene Profi, kann man nach dem Stream natürlich immer hinschreiben Einsteiger
und wenn dich einer fragt, woher weißt du das, dann sagst du von Wubblors auf Twitch
und dann sagen die natürlich, ach der Wubblors auf Twitch, ja klar, das ja verstehe ich,
das ist in Ordnung, das ist okay, dann verstehe ich das, ich bin 37, wir suchen bei der Aventur
für Passwörter, Infra, Konfigmanagement, hattest du nicht eben auch die Frage gestellt,
ob man die Datei auch noch fair und entschlüsseln kann, warst du das, du kannst jetzt ruhig
verschreiben, ich habe den zweiten Chat live an, du kannst die Datei glaube ich nicht
direkt mit dem eingebauten fair und entschlüsseln, was du machen kannst ist, du kannst das.net
Tool für User Secrets verwenden, dann speichert der User Secrets außerhalb des Projektverzeichnisses,
das ist für Entwicklungsgeschichten ganz praktisch, wenn du aber wirklich deine Konfigdatei
fair und entschlüsseln willst, dann musst du glaube ich was eigenes bauen, das dürfte
gut gehen, weil du mittlerweile bei der Standard.net Geschichte an vielen Stellen irgendwelche Zwischenhooks
reinhauen kannst, das müsste aber gehen, ich glaube aber nicht, dass das eingebaut
ist mit dem Datei fair und entschlüsseln, die beste Variante ist allerdings einfach
abfragen, bei ASP.net zum Beispiel ob du in Development läuft oder nicht, und wenn
du in Development läufst, dann nimmst du die Secrets aus dem lokalen Secretverzeichnis
und wenn du nicht in Development läufst, dann musst du den Key Vault registrieren,
also ich würde Secrets gar nicht in die JSON Config reinschreiben, also bei größeren
Anwendungen, bei einem simplen Kommando Zeilen Tool selbstverständlich, wo denn sonst hin,
also du willst bei einem simplen Kommando Zeilen Tool bestimmt kein Keystore anbinden
oder sowas, ja dann schon, aber wenn das eine Anwendung ist, die irgendwo entwickelt,
gebaut, deployed wird, als generelles Tool, bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es hauptsächlich
Azure Key Vault, es gibt aber zig andere Sachen, also was zurzeit angesagt ist, ist HashiCorp
Vault oder halt Azure Key Vault oder eben die passenden Sachen, also je nachdem in welcher
Cloud Umgebung du bist, würde ich hier jeweiligen Key Vault nehmen von AWS oder Google oder
Azure und ansonsten ist Vault relativ angesagt und ansonsten keine Ahnung, ja für Infrastruktur
Config Management, ich kann hier nicht mehr richtig reden, für Infrastruktur und Config
Management würde ich gucken was mein Schwerpunkt ist, Vault hat kein brauchbares Interface
für Noobs, achso du willst irgendein Web Interface haben, da gibt es doch bestimmt ein fertiges
Web Interface für, ich hab das noch nicht benutzt, ich weiß, keine Ahnung, fällt mir
jetzt nichts ein, zumindest bei Infrastruktur und Config Management würde ich drauf gucken,
was denn der Schwerpunkt ist, also braucht man eher Infrastruktur Management oder braucht
man eher, das konnte man selbst hausen, braucht man eher Config Management, wenn Config Management
dann eindeutig Ansible, was anderes würde ich nicht mehr verwenden, es sei denn man
ist ein Team komplett aus Entwicklern, dann könnte man vielleicht noch sowas wie Chef
verwenden, Chef ist das coole, es ist quasi komplett Ruby Syntax, aber Ansible ist das
deutlich verbreitete, mein Gott, haben die nicht einfach mal ein simples Example, einfach
mal ein simples Example hier irgendwie, ja, also wer Ruby mag, aber ansonsten würde ich
ganz klar sagen Ansible als Config Management und Terraform als Infrastruktur Management,
wenn du feststellst, du bist eigentlich, dir geht es eigentlich eher um die Infrastruktur,
dann Terraform mit irgendeiner minimalen Cloud-Init-Config und fertig, wenn es dir mehr
um Config Management geht, gerade von Systemen, die eben aufgebaut werden und dann ne Weile
dastehen, dann Ansible, so, oder Ansible, genau, wir gucken uns übrigens demnächst
Pulumi an, das ist eine Terraform Alternative, die man in.NET programmieren kann, also 2010
hätte ich mich drüber gefreut, heute ist es glaube ich als Einsteiger auch noch ganz
ok, tja, da kann ich nichts zu sagen, ja ich weiß, ich wirke nicht unbedingt wie als 37,
wie viele 37 jährigen Leute kennt ihr, die FyFat und Poggers sagen oder ihre Programme
Postchamp nennen oder die nicht lachen, sondern sagen Kekkel, ich glaube da gibt es nicht
so viele, aber immer mehr, immer mehr, zweimal du und DanceGaming, DanceGaming ist glaube
ich auch ungefähr so alt wie ich, DanceGaming Age, ne 33, ok ne, der ist 5 Jahre jünger
noch, ich bin der zoomigste Boomer, genau, ups, ich hab jetzt meine Maus runtergeschmissen,
Kekkel, ähm, dumm dumm dumm, hast du eine Ahnung was ein Niedungsapp mit meinem Provider
vermieden, ja, also stimmt, da wollte ich noch was zu sagen, jetzt kommt halt ein bisschen
drauf an, welcher Provider und was du da so machst, schwer zu sagen, wenn du da einfach
nur so Basic Admin Sachen machst, ja, keine Ahnung, ab und zu mal die Logs rotieren wenn
die Platte voll wird oder so, ja da gibt es viele die das können, ich meine immer noch
weniger als Windows Admins, Windows Admins gibt es an jeder Ecke mit dem Unterschied
dass es Windows Admins die wirklich Ahnung haben auch nicht viele gibt, aber es gibt
ganz viele Windows Admins, weil jeder denkt er kann den Windows ein bisschen rumklicken,
das ist ja auch was was ich für kein Geld der Welt machen würde Leute, Windows administrieren,
gibt es jemanden im Chat der die die Ehre hat Windows administrieren zu müssen und noch
andere Fragen gibt es jemand der Windows administrieren muss und das gerne macht, soll es ja auch
geben wir haben bei uns oft bei uns dort wo ich jetzt arbeite haben wir auch ein paar
Windows Admins die das gerne machen, PowerShell ja das, das würde ich eigentlich von einem
ordentlichen Windows Admin auch erwarten, dass der PowerShell kann, aber ich kenne genug
die das nicht können, aber das sind ja auch keine ordentlichen Windows Admins, das sind
eben die 0815 Klicker die du an jeder Ecke findest
Ja kann man sich denke ich als Junior Entwickler auch echt nicht beschweren, zumal Full Home
Office wirklich super ist, wenn es bei der jeweiligen Firma dann auch organisatorisch
passt, aber ganz ehrlich Full Time Home Office wäre auch was wo ich dann sagen würde ja
gut, da kann ich auch ein bisschen weniger leben, mein Schaf bin ich nicht drauf, aber
ich spare dadurch ja auch viel Geld, wenn der Rest halt passt
Oh ich bin ziemlich hinten dran im Chat, es ist halt so ja ist echt so
Muss man krasse, komplexe, mathematische Probleme lösen, nein muss man nicht
Man muss logisch denken können, aber du musst keine mathematischen Beweise oder so aufbringen
Ne ne musst du nicht
Serious Max Dankeschön für 24 Monate Hypersubscription, Massive Sub, warte mal Sekunde, wo ist es, exzellent
Modge, haben wir eigentlich Mod, Mod haben wir irgendwas mit, ne wir haben bloß Mod,
wir haben bloß Modcheck
Ja Leute einmal für den Serious Max Modcheck im Chat hier, brauchen wir jetzt, das hat
er verdient, nicht nur für die 24 Monate Subscription, sondern auch weil er das Archiv programmiert
hat, weil er immer den Chat so schön moderiert, weil er die heute Messages setzt und weil
er mittlerweile Massive Big Brain ist, wie alle hier im Chat
Ja ist das nicht dieses Portal, wo du unter anderem CCNA Prüfung üben kannst und Packet
Tracer bekommst und sowas
Boah Fußball kein Plan
Sind die nicht beide auch ziemlich alt mittlerweile
Die sind doch fast so alt wie ich mittlerweile sogar oder, die gibt es doch auch schon ewig
ja, wundert euch wen, die ganzen Microsoft Prüfungen sind so bescheuert
Also keine, muss ich ehrlich sagen, also die ganzen Asher Schulungs waren insgesamt 2,
3, warte mal, lass mal überlegen, AZ 400, AZ 900
Ich glaube es waren 2 mal eine Woche oder so
Ne, ne, ne, stimmt nicht, Asher DevOps haben wir noch gemacht
3, 3 Asher Schulungen waren es, die waren alle nicht gut
Das lag aber gar nicht mal so sehr an den Leuten, die die Schulung gemacht haben
Kennst du das Linux Hotel, ne schick mal einen Link
Es war weil Microsoft diese Asher Schulungen so gehalten haben möchte
Also Asher Schulungen sind, der Typ macht Powerpoint auf und liest dir einzelne Punkte
vom Powerpoint vor
Microsoft will, dass diese Schulungen so laufen, das ist richtig, richtig, richtig dämlich
Niklas, danke für den Zap
Bist du Herr Endpunkt?
Ich weiß nämlich nicht, wie Herr Endpunkt auf Twitch heißt
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht
Das Linux Hotel
Was ist das denn, also die Webseite sieht schon mal passend aus dafür
Na ok, mit Lightseam sieht die tatsächlich noch ganz brauchbar aus
Das Linux Hotel
Hotel WG, MonkaS
Und warum sollte man da hin?
Oh nein, ich hab den Chat zugemacht, fuck
MonkaS
Wo bin ich stehen geblieben Leute?
Was, Moment, Moment, was war das letzte?
Jetzt ist vorbei
Ich habe aber noch einen zweiten, ich habe noch einen Backup, ich habe noch einen Backup
vom Chat
Hier, da bin ich stehen geblieben
Niklas-Subscriber, genau
Wie viele Arbeitgeber hast du schon gewechselt?
Zwei
Was hast du schon mal, was zehnmal Dev in freier Wildbahn gesehen ist, verstehe ich nicht,
keine Ahnung
Wie kam der Wechsel von Feasy auf DevOps, das war kein Wechsel, das war fließender Übergang
Ja, das ist mein Ziel für 2023, das Stream löst Stack Overflow ab, genau
So wird das
Hat sich das auf der Arbeit, ah interessante Frage, ok
Hat sich das auf der Arbeit geklärt mit Homeoffice, nö
Die wollen immer noch, dass ich vermehrt auf die Arbeit komme
Aktuell ist es so, schwank zwischen eins bis zwei Tage die Woche
Was auch der Grund ist, warum ich weiter nach was neu im Suche
Weil zwei Tage sind 50% meiner Arbeitszeiten, da habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock drauf
Zumal ich merke, dass ich bei den Tagen, wo ich vor Ort bin, quasi so gut wie nichts
auf die Reihe kriege versus die Homeoffice Tage
Ich habe keine Ahnung, achso warum die das möchten, die möchten nicht, dass ich ins Büro
komme
Das ist so eine allgemeine sinnlos Ansage
Was Terraform, um einen Cloud Formation Stack zu deployen, das war das beste Projekt des
heutigen Tages
Also bin ich jetzt irgendwie ultra noobig, wenn ich nicht weiß, was ein Cloud Formation
Stack ist
Und wenn jetzt einer sagt, es ist was in der Cloud, dann bin ich da auch nicht so wirklich
Ach AWS, ok nee, AWS ist die Cloud, die ich am wenigsten kenne
Google bisschen, Azure relativ gut
Liebe internationale Firma oder Lokale, ganz ehrlich, ist mir ziemlich egal
Solange es 100% nicht Homeoffice ist und ich da nicht hin muss
Ansonsten mit meinem krassen Business Englisch komme ich da bestimmt ohne Probleme weiter
Ich koche jetzt, sodass ich nichts übersehen habe
Was ist denn hier der letzte Stream
Gurki, dann sag denen, dass du mehr Geld haben willst
Du musst die regelmäßig nerven
Und gerade wenn sie sich irgendwelche Ausreden einfallen lassen, so nach dem Motto
Ah, gerade ist doch Inflation und Corona und so nah, für uns ist es so schlecht
Die werden sich immer irgendwas ausdenken, warum es gerade ganz schlecht der Zeitpunkt
ist
Du musst die wirklich regelmäßig nerven mit mehr Kohle
Muss denen richtig auf den Sack gehen
Und am besten natürlich auch immer so weit stichhaltig, dass die eigentlich gar nichts
dagegen sagen können, gegen deinen du willst mehr Geld
Sondern dass die nicht anders können, als zu sagen, ja gerade schlecht, weil Corona und
so
Ich habe in dem Fall schon mal gewonnen, wenn sie nämlich nichts dazu sagen können, dass
es an dir liegt
Was es wahrscheinlich auch nicht macht
Dann kommen sie da auf Dauer halt nicht graus aus der Nummer
Ja das ist immer so dieses
Genau, wollte ich gerade sagen, gerade wenn einer mit Inflation ankommt, muss er sagen
ja und die habe ich doch auch
Gerade deswegen muss mehr Kohle her
Und ich meine, wenn gar nichts hilft
Also ich habe es bei einem Kollegen gesehen, bei mir, bei dem war es genauso
Der macht richtig viel
Das ist einer der Leute, die sich wirklich Mühe geben und auch mal selbst sich um Themen
kümmert
Und der hat wirklich nicht viel Geld bekommen
Und gerade auch in Anbetracht dessen, wenn ich sehe, was der macht, was ist das, was
Leute aus seinem Team machen, die mehr bekommen
Es hat komplett nicht angemessen gewesen
Und das einzige, was bei dem geholfen hat ist
Der hat sich einen Stackoverflow, Quatsch, keinen Stackoverflow, einen Stackoverflow Account
hatte er auch
Der hat sich einen LinkedIn Account gemacht und ein paar andere Accounts und hat sich
umgeguckt
Hat auch mehrere Vorstellungsgespräche gemacht
Und hat ein paar Angebote bekommen und hat dann bei der Firma gesagt, also da wo ich
jetzt arbeite, gesagt Jungs, also guck mal hier
Wir haben ja schon viele Gespräche geführt über Perspektiven und sonst was, nie ist
was passiert
Ich habe mich jetzt umgehört, dort bekomme ich das und wenn sich da bei uns nichts tut,
bin ich zum nächsten Kündigungstermin weg
Das ist natürlich nicht das, was man standardmäßig machen sollte
Ganz ehrlich, finde ich ein bisschen assi, wenn man bei allem immer drohen muss und
nach dem Auto habe, bin ich weg
Und es dann quasi, also rein aus Taktik macht ja
Wenn es halt wirklich die Absicht ist, ok, warum sollte man es nicht sagen
Aber auf der anderen Seite, manchmal hilft es anscheinend nicht anders
Man muss dann aber halt im Zweifelsfall auch sagen, ja, dann haue ich halt ab
Es ist bei uns ähnlich aktuell, jetzt nicht exakt so
Bei uns ist es auch so
Die haben erst große Töne gespuckt, was Homeoffice angeht
Und auch mit möglicher Vertragsänderung und Mobilarbeiten und so
Und jetzt haben sie den kompletten Rückzieher gemacht
Also ich bin, ich weiß es, dass ich nicht der einzige bin, der sich umguckt aktuell
Und ich wäre sicherlich auch nicht der einzige sein, der schon Vorstellungsgespräche und
sonstige Sachen geführt hat
Also von einem bei mir aus dem Team weiß ich es, der hat Pläne, nächstes Jahr, Anfang
des Jahres abzuhauen
Weil halt Kündigungsfrist und alles
Und es sind auch schon ein paar abgehauen und ich habe gehört, dass sie mittlerweile
auf einen Schlag jetzt gesagt haben, wir suchen 45 neue Leute für die IT
Also da seht ihr mal, das müssen erstens ordentlich Mangel da sein und zweitens, viele
Leute auch schon abgesprungen sein
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch erzählt habe, was meint ihr denn, wie viele Leute haben die
schon gefunden
Für, von diesen 45 Leuten
Also ich weiß, das ist IT Gesamt, sucht 45 Leute, aber ich weiß es von ein paar Teams,
wie viele die schon gefunden haben und naja, die haben 0 bis 2 gefunden
Also die haben für einen Support einen gefunden, der schon da war und dem haben sie jetzt einen
Vertrag geschickt
Und man weiß noch nicht, ob er unterschreibt
Und für das Team, in dem ich bin, wurde wohl um 3 Ecken einer angeworben, der hat aber
auch noch nicht unterschrieben
Also sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft, von 45 Leuten, die sie haben wollen, 2 potenzielle
Kandidaten zu finden, die aber noch beide nicht unterschrieben haben
Also, nicht so geile Ausbeute
Ok, ich hab's geschafft, ich bin im Chat wieder ran gescrollt, alles klar
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken, ob ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen hab
Ja, gestern, ne warte mal, was ist heute Mittwoch?
Ok, ja doch, gestern, gestern, also gestern muss ich sagen, die Firma fand, also zumindest
das war sie, was sie mir erzählt haben, weil ich mein, das ist ja im Prinzip immer ein
bisschen, das ist so wie in den ganzen Anzeigen, da ist auch immer erstmal erster Absatz so
nach dem Motto, wir sind die tollste Firma, aber unabhängig davon, das hatte schon Hand
und Fuß und das hat mich rein von der Arbeit und von der Firma her schon überzeugt, gestern
muss ich sagen, gehaltsmäßig sind wir uns auch so ungefähr einig, ich mein, die konkrete
Zahl ist noch nicht in Stein gemeißelt, aber wir haben uns da gut verstanden, waren uns
eigentlich auch über die Arbeit einig, also das würde passen, das würde passen, gehaltsmäßig
müssen wir noch mal unterm Strich gucken, das hat zumindest so gut gepasst, dass wir
uns jetzt drauf geeinigt haben, ich mach mal einen Probe-Arbeitstag und mal gucken, direkt
Produktion crashen, ich glaube nicht, dass ich an einem Probe-Tag Login krieg für Protz-Systeme.
Probe-Tage, nee ich finde Probe-Tage gut, wisst ihr warum, ich fand das lange Zeit auch
bescheuert, so nach dem Motto, warum soll ich Probe-Tage machen, Alter, da muss ich
ja, nee, also, warum ich Probe-Tage mittlerweile gut finde ist, in so Vorstellungsgesprächen
kann sich das immer ganz anders darstellen, als, wenn man mit den Leuten arbeitet und
du kennst halt die Leute nicht, du kennst den Chef oder den Teamleiter vielleicht, aber
du kennst nicht die Leute, vielleicht kommst du mit irgendwelchen Leuten gar nicht klar,
vielleicht stellst du auch fest, boah nee, das ist doch nichts, also es ist mal was anderes,
du hast eine deutlich bessere Vorstellung davon, was sich erwartet, wenn du mal, Probe-Tag kann
ja auch noch 4 Stunden, halben Tag oder mal irgendwie 2 Stunden, was auch immer, kann
ja alles Mögliche sein, gemacht hast, also deswegen würde ich sagen, ich würde nach
Möglichkeit immer einen Probe-Tag machen, ich muss nicht extra Urlaub nehmen, weil ich
hab montags frei, ich kann montags einfach einen Probe-Tag machen, je nachdem wie lange
der lang geht, ich kann den einfach montags machen, ich muss nicht frei nehmen, willst
du nicht fulltime, nein will ich nicht, das erzählen mir Leute schon seit 10 Jahren,
ich meine ich mach Youtube seit 2010, kann man sich kaum vorstellen, aber ist schon so
lange, nee Moment, seit 12 Jahren Alter, das erzählen mir Leute schon seit 12 Jahren,
ob ich den Kram nicht hauptberuflich machen will, nee will ich nicht, ist auch so, viel
produktiver und vor allem viel störungsfreier, ja hast du richtig verstanden, also wenn du
irgendwie eine coole Stelle hast, oder vielleicht selbst an der Stelle bist, wo sowas entschieden
wird, schreib mir ruhig gerne eine Mail an meine Business-E-Mail-Adresse, die steht
im Twitch-Profil, also wenn jemand gute Jobs hat, ich guck mir versprochen, ich guck mir
alle Mails an, ob es dann passt, müssen wir gucken, wie lange bist du schon da, 10 Jahre
ungefähr, ist schon ein bisschen, ungefähr 10 Jahre schon, ich hätte dieses Jahr jetzt,
das weiß ich sogar genau, es sind tatsächlich ungefähr 10 Jahre, weil ich hätte dieses
Jahr so eine 10-Jahres-Jubiläums-Veranstaltung und da habe ich letztens eine Mail bekommen,
Herr Max, wir freuen uns, Sie zur 10-Jahres-Jubiläums-Feier einladen zu dürfen und unten drunter,
das war dann so richtig Lobgesang, Lobpreisung und wisst ihr was ich gemacht habe, direkt
über das Formular, was man anklicken konnte in der Mail, dreimal dürft ihr raten, was
ich gemacht habe, direkt, als ich die Mail bekommen habe, Absage, korrekt, ich hab direkt
abgesagt, so Real-Life-Veranstaltungen abends, wo dann auch noch im Zweifelsfall der Vorstand
mit dabei sitzt, das ist bei uns immer so ein riesen Ding, ja, da kommt IT-Chef, Vorstand,
sogar, sogar, was ist das für eine Position, also alles mögliche, alles mögliche kommt
da und ganz ehrlich, ich will mich mit denen nicht da abends hinsetzen und sagen, hier,
Alter, was geht oder, da hab ich echt keinen Bock drauf, ich weiß weder, was ich mit denen
erzählen soll, noch was ich, das ist dann so ein Abend mit Entertainment und sowas, sprich,
man geht dann zu irgendeinem Event, kriegt dann da irgendwie Abendprogramm, kriegt dann
Essen und Trinken, ich hab da keine, für mich ist sowas ätzend, ich mach sowas nicht
gerne.
Ja, schwer zu sagen, also bei uns ist es halt so, wir haben einen relativ großen Standort
in Frankfurt und ja, den bezahlen die, ob die Leute drinnen sitzen oder nicht, also ich
denke nicht, dass die so viel Ersparnisse haben durch Homeoffice, die haben insofern
den Vorteil durch Homeoffice, weil die Leute produktiver sind, ja, und weniger Zeit hin
und zurückfahren brauchen und mal bereiter sind auch mal abends was zu machen, aber ansonsten
weiß ich nicht, ob die massig Geld dadurch, also ich spar massig Geld, ja, hab ich heute
auch gehört, hab ich heute auch gehört, ah, im Winter, im Winter wirds wieder ganz schlimm
und ich denke mir so, da konnte doch jeder mit rechnen, so, so, so, erzählt mal was
Neues und sorg doch mal dafür, dass es nicht wie letztes Jahr läuft, im Sommer alle Kopf
in den Sand gesteckt, so nach dem Motto, ach wird doch nicht so schlimm, wird doch nicht
so schlimm, sondern dass man sich jetzt ordentlich mal drauf vorbereitet, kann doch nicht, man
kann doch nicht immer, gerade wenn man in der Position ist, kann man nicht immer rumschauen,
oh nein, das wird ganz schlimm, dann soll man halt auch mal erzählen, ja, was macht
man denn zur Vorbereitung, wobei ich sagen muss, ganz im Ernst, jetzt noch mal eine aktuelle
Sache, diese ganze Diskussion mit Gaspreisen und, und, dass Leute vielleicht frieren müssen
im Winter, das finde ich, schlägt über, es schlägt, also es schlägt Wellen, ja, aber
ich finde es schlägt die falschen Wellen, es müsste eigentlich Wellen schlagen in Richtung,
wie absolut unfähig wurden eigentlich Entscheidungen getroffen die letzten 10 Jahre über, das
ist eigentlich, wie kann es sein, dass wir als viertreichstes Land der Welt ernsthaft
uns Gedanken darüber machen müssen, ob es bei uns vielleicht Leute gibt, die nicht genug
Geld haben und im Winter frieren müssen, die Leute diskutieren eher darüber, ha, soll
ich mir noch einen Radiator kaufen oder nicht oder sonst was, wie kann es sein, dass das
viertreichste Land der Welt wirklich darüber diskutiert, dass Leute frieren im Winter,
das verstehe ich nicht, ich finde, in diese Richtung sollte die Diskussion gehen, wie
beschissen kann man eigentlich regieren, dass das so ist, und ja, mir ist klar, dass da
unsere aktuelle Regierung nicht unbedingt die größte Teil der Sache dran trägt, ja,
das ist das, wo eigentlich mal eine Diskussion hingehen sollte, ja, könnte man tatsächlich
mal machen, glaube erst mal nichts, was die Leute im Internet erzählen, wer weiß, ob
das alles so stimmt, genau so ist es, ähm, warum, also es gibt mehrere Gründe, es gibt
viele Sachen, die mich nerven bei der Firma, wo ich aktuell arbeite, ja, von wie dort
Projekte geführt werden, wie teilweise mit Leuten umgegangen wird, wie teilweise immer
Dinge angekündigt werden und nicht passieren, wie man immer wieder gegen seine eigenen Sachen,
die man doch jetzt doch wirklich endlich mal machen will, verstößt, es gibt viele Sachen,
die mich bei der aktuellen Firma aufregen, ähm, bei Gehaltsfragen wird sich auch immer
sehr drum herum gedrückt, so nach dem Motto, ah, aktuell ist es ganz schlecht und ah, hm,
ich weiß nicht, aber das ist gar nicht der Hauptpunkt, der Hauptpunkt ist, dass sie
mit ganz viel Tamtam, äh, vorgestellt haben, Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten, mobile Arbeitsmöglichkeiten
und individuelle Regelungen für Mitarbeiter und sonst was und jetzt 180 Grad Kehrtwende
gemacht haben, was dieses Thema angeht und nachdem ich jetzt die letzten zweieinhalb Jahre
fast ausschließlich mit kurzen Unterbrechungen Homeoffice gearbeitet habe, weiß ich, wie
gut das funktioniert, dass ich mehr schaffe und dass es mir noch besser geht dabei, ich
sehe das nicht ein und ich habe jetzt mit meinem aktuellen Chef ganz gute, ja, Übergangsregelung
erstmal getroffen, so nach dem Motto, zwei Tage, ja, wenn es mal ein Tag ist, ist es
vielleicht auch nicht so wild, aber man darf nicht vergessen, zwei Tage sind 50% meiner
Arbeitszeit und das sehe ich nicht ein, obwohl es besser läuft und ich hoffe, also ich warte
noch auf den Tag, wo sich dann irgendjemand beschwert, ähm, dass ich nicht mehr so viel
auf die Reihe kriege wie letztes Jahr, was sage ich, ihr wollt, dass ich hierher fahre
und Zeit verschwende, nicht ich.
So, also hauptsächlich geht es mir um Homeoffice-Thematik und also ich bin generell schon ziemlich
abgefuckt, was viele Themen angeht, aber das sind alles so Dinger, ich denke Probleme
gibt es überall, ja, das wären jetzt alles keine Probleme, weshalb ich jetzt wirklich
sagen würde, jetzt wird es mal akut, aber mit dieser Homeoffice-Thematik und mit der
Entwicklung, dass sie quasi sich 180 Grad gedreht haben von, oder sagen wir mal so,
sie haben sich 90 Grad gedreht, ja, sie haben gesagt, mobiles Arbeiten, individuelle Regelungen,
Homeoffice, alles ganz toll wird das jetzt und sie haben sich um 90 Grad gedreht und
haben gesagt, ach nee, doch nicht und ich kenne halt die Firma, wo ich arbeite, das
sind so viele Boomer in den Entscheidungspositionen, es kann durchaus sein, dass dann irgendwann
Ende des Jahres jemand sagt, aber übrigens Leute, ab 2023 wieder 100% Anwesenheit und
das ist dann halt wirklich der Stichtag, wo ich sage, ja, dann bin ich aber nicht mehr
anwesend und genau aus dem Grund gucke ich jetzt schon, weil ich hatte gestern ein Vorstellungsgespräch
und das war muss ich sagen, seit ewiger Zeit mal das erste Vorstellungsgespräch, was
ich je hatte und ich hatte wirklich gleich wirklich was Gutes erwischt, ja, also es ist
genau das, was ich machen will, vom Tätigkeitsbereich her und Geld sind wir auch zumindest schon
mal die Richtung passt, wird nicht alles so gut passen und ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
also wenn ich da jetzt was finde, eins habe ich noch, die wissen von meinem YouTube, ja,
die wissen das, also zumindest der Chef weiß das, deswegen hat er mich auch angeschrieben,
also das war tatsächlich einer dieser Mails, die ich bekommen habe, ein Tag nach dem Stream,
wo ich gesagt habe, ich suche einen neuen Job und ich mein, für mich ist es ja sogar
eigentlich von Vorteil, wenn die wissen, was ich hier im Stream fabriziere und dann denken,
hey das passt für die Firma, dann haben sich viele Fragen auch schon erübrigt, also ich
finde das nicht schlecht und ja, ich habe das Vorstellungsgespräch mit Kamera angehabt,
ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich jetzt auch mal einen neuen Job habe, also das ist ein guter
Gehalt, ich finde es ist auch ein gutes Gehalt dafür, wie gesagt, wenn ich in Frankfurt so
rumgucke, es gibt durchaus Leute, die noch mehr kriegen und gerade wenn du auch noch
ordentlich Überstunden machst, dann müssen sie auch ordentlich bezahlen, ich hoffe du
hast nicht so einen komischen Vertrauensarbeitszeit Vertrag, wo es dann im Endeffekt nur darauf
rausläuft, dass du umsonst mehr arbeitest.
Was sind denn 10 mal Devs, Leute?
10 mal Devs sind Devs, die 10 mal produktiver sind, als
10 normale Devs in Relation, dann würde ich mich eher mal fragen, was ich für normale
Devs habe, also du hast sicherlich die ein oder andere Absolut Fivehead, Leute, wenn
einer vielleicht, sag mal mal so, wenn einer Teilzeit arbeitet wie ich und der kriegt ungefähr
das hin, was jemand anderes in 5 Tagen hinkriegt, das würde ich sagen, ok, das ist doch realistisch,
aber dass einer 10 mal mehr schafft als alle anderen, dann würde ich mich eher fragen,
sind die anderen denn auch wirklich Entwickler?
Nee, also das finde ich, das klingt ziemlich blödsinnig.
Naja, wenn man sich mal diesen, wir haben noch letztens im Spiegel mal diesen Deutschland-Gehaltsdurchschnitt
angeguckt, da sind wir hier alle schon relativ gut, das ist nicht sonderlich hoch.
Also, die hatten da so einen Durchschnitt, wo es kein Durchschnitt war, sondern es war,
ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt, wenn man quasi mal so die Allerreichsten und Allerärmsten
irgendwie wegnimmt und dann guckt, ok, was ist denn realistisch der Durchschnitt, ja,
weil wenn du irgendwie dann eine Handvoll Milliardäre hast, hebst du das halt auch mal
ein bisschen.
Ja, und das war gar nicht so hoch, wie man denkt, wo war denn das, 32k oder so, das war
wirklich nicht hoch.
Ich darf gar nicht dran denken, weil jemand sagt, er verdient so und so viel vor den Steuern,
ich darf gar nicht verdienen, überlegen, wie viel es eigentlich um Gehaltszettel immer
steht vor den Steuern.
Das kenn ich auch, bei uns ist es auch so, die stellen manchmal lieber externe als interne
ein, obwohl die irgendwie 5x mehr kosten, weil da noch irgendeine Personalvermittlung
dazwischen ist oder sonst was und ich weiß, dass es bei uns manchmal aus taktischen Gründen
ist, erstens wirst du externe schneller los und zweitens, je nachdem wie groß die Firma
ist, kann es auch sein, dass du dann einen neuen Betriebsratssitz bekommst, ab einer
gewissen Größe, wenn du die überschreitest und sowas, also da hängt teilweise schon
ein bisschen mehr dran, wie sehr sich das lohnt, oh es ist wirklich schon spät Leute,
schnell.
Hahaha, das ist ja geil, tja, ok wenn mich einer an Mac setzen würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich
auch nichts auf die Reihe kriegen, weil ich nicht viel Plan habe von Mac, ich komm ja
allein schon mit der Control-Taste nicht richtig klar.
Glaubst du, dass der Fachkräftemangel real ist, hab ich schonmal ein Video dazu gemacht,
also ich glaube, wenn du es nach der Definition machst, also wir sind übrigens gerade, oh
man bin ich, fuck bin ich weit hinten im Chat, sag ich gleich was zu, ich muss nochmal schnell
den anderen Kram durchscrollen.
Äh, ich hab schon kleine Sachen nebenher gemacht, ja, nix, Abstand von Filmfeiern,
das frag ich mich auch, wie das geht, naja, wir sind das Land mit dem viertgrößten,
wie heißt das, Einkommen, Bruttoinlandsprodukt oder Bruttodings, da Stonksbegriffe, alter
hört mir auf.
Also was das angeht, sind wir das viertgrößte Land der Welt, gleich Bett gehen, wann nächster
Stream?
Äh, die Tage, so, also jetzt wollte ich ja noch was beantworten, glaubst du, das letzte
was ich jetzt, wo ich jetzt was zu sage, weil ansonsten wird es echt zu spät, also, glaubst
du, dass der Fachkräftemangel real ist, also, wenn man das nach den Definitionen vom Arbeitsamt
macht und wie da Statistiken erfasst werden und wie Bitcom immer rumhollt, dann ja, weil
es findet nicht jeder einen, der einen sucht, aber Unternehmen, die Fachkräfte suchen und
dementsprechend Anreize und ordentliche Bedingungen bieten, die finden welche, also ja, es gibt
ein Fachkräftemangel, dass nicht jede dahergelaufene Klitsche, die nix bezahlen will, zugeschissen
wird mit Fachkräften, wenn man das so definiert, gibt es Fachkräftemangel, aber wenn es darum
geht, wenn man sich Mühe gibt, Leute zu finden, dann nicht und das hat letztens auch mal irgendein
Personalverschacherungstyp-Vermittler gesagt, in irgendeinem Video, was wir geguckt haben,
das fand ich ziemlich gut, der hat gesagt, heutzutage reicht es nicht mehr, einfach irgendwelche
Stellenanzeigen zu schalten oder als Personalvermittler nur auf LinkedIn oder sonst wie rumzulungern,
heutzutage ist es wichtig, dass man versucht, aktiv die Leute anzusprechen, die beschäftigt
sind, also dass man nicht nur versucht, Arbeitslose oder Leute, die wirklich kurz verwechseln sind
anzusprechen, sondern dass man auch versuchen muss, Leute anzusprechen, die unzufrieden
sind bzw. innerlich schon gekündigt haben und da gibt es, bin ich mir relativ sicher,
einen recht hohen Prozentsatz, ich weiß nicht wie viele, aber ich denke mal 20, 20, wenn
nicht 30% der Leute haben innerlich eigentlich schon gar keinen Bock mehr auf das, wo sie
aktuell arbeiten, ja die sagen, der Laden geht mir unglaublich auf den Keks, ich bin
aber noch zu faul, mir was neues zu suchen, also quasi der Leidensdruck ist noch nicht
groß genug, aber innerlich haben sie schon gesagt, ich sitze hier meine Zeit, aber ich
mache Dienst nach Vorschrift und sonst was, so und das ist glaube ich bei vielen so und
deswegen muss man eben als Personalvermittlung oder als Recruiter oder als Firma, die dann
die Leute sucht, muss man auch versuchen, aktiv solche Leute anzusprechen, hat letztendlich
so ein Personalvermittlungstyp mal in einem Video gesagt und das fand ich eigentlich
sehr sinnvoll und aus diesen Gesichtspunkten glaube ich nicht, dass es einen richtigen Fachkräftemangel
gibt, in Form von man findet nichts mehr, wenn man sich Mühe gibt, die Umfrage machen wir
schnell noch, falls ein Mod da ist, macht mal please, bis ich unten im Chat ankomme,
diese Umfrage von Babi mit wie viele Leute was neues nehmen würden, wenn sie jetzt ein
gutes Angebot bekommen würden, also ich glaube jeder der sich Mühe gibt und ordentlichen
Job bietet, ordentliches Gehalt bietet, ordentliche Arbeitsbedingungen bietet findet was, ja Sommerfest
zählt nicht als Arbeitszeit, da will ich halt nicht hingehen, ich würde dann meinen Tag
machen bis 15.30 und abhauen, da hast du recht, aber das trifft für alle zu, der Durchschnittstester
ist Crap, der Durchschnittsadmin ist Crap, das ist überall so, die meisten, also Großteil
der Leute taugen nichts, das ist interessant, ja ok, jetzt mal, guck mal Leute, sagen wir
mal 15%, sagen wir mal 15%, oder warten wir mal bis die Umfrage fertig ist, ja, jetzt
kommen die Leute noch hinten drauf, ok, guck mal, 25%, Moment, man konnte mit Channelpoints
abstimmen, wait a minute, so ist die Umfrage aber nicht so nicht repräsentativ, ja, Kackel
Alter, ok Leute, wir machen die Umfrage das nächste Mal nochmal, aber gehen wir mal von
15-20% aus, gehen wir mal von 15-20% aus, es hat sich jetzt komplett umgeschmeckt, also
gehen wir mal von 15-20% aus, das ist tatsächlich was, was Personalvermittler ansprechen sollen
oder Recruiter ansprechen sollten, ja, ich würde sagen, es gibt Probleme auf allen Ebenen,
was zu finden, klar, es ist ein bisschen einfacher Einsteiger zu finden, einfach weil es wahrscheinlich
mehr Einsteiger gibt, als jetzt Experten in gewissem Gebiet, aber ich glaube das Problem
gibt es überall, und ich denke wie gesagt, wenn du ordentliche Bedingungen bietest, ordentliches
Gehalt bietest oder eben, sagen wir mal, drücken wir es anders aus, wenn du die richtigen Anreize
bietest, dann kommen die Leute zu dir, ja, privatem Interesse und Prime Subscription bei
Publors natürlich, da sind wir uns einig, weil 150 EQ Chat kommt nicht von alleine,
klar, natürlich, klar, warum nicht, klar, natürlich stellen wir noch 45-jährige ein,
wir haben bei uns, glaube ich, einen fast 80-jährigen Netzwerk Techniker, nein, ganz so krass alt
ist er noch nicht, 75-jährigen Netzwerk Techniker, der ist eigentlich schon in Rente, zumindest
vom Alter her, das ist genau so eine blöde Frage, wie wenn umgedreht kommt, wo sehen sie
sich in 10 Jahren und so ein Blödsinn, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das fragen würde, Leute,
jetzt ist der Hype Train am Start und jetzt gehe ich off, das ist natürlich wieder bester
Taktik, zetzel, Dankeschön für den Sub, Leute, ich gehe jetzt off, keine Chance, egal
ob Hype Train oder sonst was, ich muss morgen früh aufstehen, 22.30, ich gehe jetzt ins
Bett, wir sehen uns, macht es gut im nächsten Stream, Hype Train, ich bin wahrscheinlich
der einzige, der im Hype Train den Stream ausmacht, macht es gut, keck, bye, bis zum
nächsten Stream.